so da bin ich
gleich ist wie im letzten stream nicht wundern wenn ich ab und zu mal huste oder wenn es irgendwie
am mikrofon kratzt ich habe so einen komischen schal an wegen meinem hals aber das hält mir
ja bestimmt corona ja was sonst es gibt keine anderen krankheiten mehr seit corona wann habt
ihr was von einer anderen krankheit gehört seit corona raus ist seit corona release gibt
es keine anderen krankheiten mehr ob obviously
das gibt es nicht mehr hört man hört man recht wenig von ist alles alles ausgestorben jetzt
es gibt noch low iq aber da kann man nichts dagegen machen auch ein bisschen groß vielleicht
quasi 3 hat ja und und weiter drunter noch ja das ist wohl wahr also ich möchte weder
das eine noch das andere und alles zusammen ist natürlich auch nicht so sinnvoll nee
besch näher kommt drauf an mal wenn leute ich wink euch mal guck mal ja hallo ruckels ruckels
sekunde 1 2 3 leute wer kann binär zählen ich krieg das ich krieg das nur ultra langsam hin 1 2 3 4
5 ach du scheiße ich kann das nicht ich bin dazu low iq für nein das war kein trick zu
mittelfinger zeigen man kann ja wirklich mit der hand binar zählen kredo dankeschön für den
sub kredo ich kenne dich von twitter du bist der der diesen komischen dicken kappa avatar
hat oder es gibt so ein paar leute die merkt man sich wegen ihrem avatar und ich glaube du
bist der mit diesem dicken dicken kappa avatar ja manche sachen merkt man sich irgendwie ja
bastel video hallo max durch deine videos bin ich aus programmieren gekommen big brain 5 hat
teile was wichtigste hast du schon mal und gestern habe ich mit meinem ersten projekt begonnen das
betrieb sind wir jetzt fast fertig ich hätte gleich weiter ich hätte gleich weiter lesen sollen
um was auch kurz gucken ob die musik lautstärke ok ist ein bisschen laut vielleicht aber wobei
passt eigentlich wo ist denn hier die musik überhaupt musik stellts da also ich bin mir
nicht so ganz sicher ob das klappt was was was wir heute vor haben ich mache kurz meine vm an
moment das ist falsch sonst bin ich verwirrt wenn das auf falschen desktop ist das muss dahin die
vm muss dahin ne ne ne nicht die cute vm tees fuchs dange für den sub leute ich habe überhaupt nicht
nachgeguckt jetzt seck wir haben auch gleich dass das den scam train der scam train läuft auch
gleich wieder und der leona bomba hat auch subscript das subscript schon dankeschön oder wie man
mein englischlehrer gesagt hat subscribiert dem ist das deutsche wort nicht eingefallen hat es
dann einfach deutsch ausgesprochen aber das war eh one hat englischlehrer in der berufsschule
der war 0,5 fett also wenn 0,5 fett auf einen zutrifft dann auf meinen englischlehrer aus
der berufsschule ganz ganz schlimm der karl da war auch ein jahr vor rente hatte keine kein bock
mehr auf nix am ende haben einfach alle zweier gekriegt fertig und jetzt machen wir mal das hier
in der vm auf weil ich glaube das ist viel sinniger und das machen wir jetzt hier auf desktop sieben
richtig 5 hat setup wieder dann machen wir jetzt watch picture in picture und dann drücken wir
windows taste s und dann ist es sticky auf allen desktops ist das nicht massivst pock
so sam taki online schon für den primes ab ein bisschen größer kommen das ganze allerdings
schon noch machen ich mache dann fullscreen ich mache dann fullscreen wenn es was zu zeigen gibt
ok wunderbar mehr pock geht nicht ja finde ich auch habt ihr übrigens schon wieder den
neuesten angeblichen outrage mitbekommen ich habe sie auf twitter gepostet substituieren
einer nicht substituieren subscribieren anstatt subscriben subscribieren glaubt nicht dass es
dieses wort gibt ja habt ihr schon den den neuen fake outrage mitbekommen wo ich glaube dass das
fake fake ist und zwar ich habe sie auf twitter gepostet also kai karotte von aldi ist ganz ganz
schlimm sagt zumindest der focus ach ja und msi hat mich immer noch gebannt ich weiß weiß bis
heute nicht warum das habe ich gelesen habe ich mir gedacht leute so bescheuert ist noch nicht
mal twitter sich darüber aufzuregen und dann habe ich mal gesucht dann habe ich mal gesucht es hat
sich auch niemand darüber aufgeregt es hat sich im prinzip nur der was war das der focus glaube
ich drüber aufgeregt dass ich angeblich leute drüber aufgeregt hätten aber ich habe nicht
mal angefunden der witz ist ja wenn sich twitter nicht aufregt dann regt sich niemand auf twitter
ist das vorzeige ding für empörung und wenn twitter sich schon hat empört dann kann es
entweder nur ein fortune troll sein oder aber es ist fake also es hat sich niemand es hat sich
niemand aufgeregt also ich ich bin mir aber ziemlich sicher hätte aldi den typ anstatt
kai karotte kai moor rübe genannt dann wäre richtig outrage angesagt gewesen auf twitter
wollen wir wetten dann wäre da wäre vorbei hier da wäre da wäre nur nicht für kfd am start da
wäre alles am start gewesen übrigens ich habe zu wenig rgb für mein weihnachtsbaum guckt mal
her ist auch einer der gründe warum ich das jetzt basteln was ich heute basteln will die kette
leicht reich plus bis hier guck mal zwei drittel vom vom baum ist rgb wunderbar ein drittel ist
keine kette mehr da was richtig bescheuert ist ich habe jetzt noch zwei stück bestellt bei amazon
ja noch zwei stück bei amazon bestellt wie gesagt die sache soll man müsst euch nicht
wundern wenn ich heute ein bisschen husten muss oder wenn es komisch kratzter mikrofon
ich habe schalten an und ein bisschen als wir immer noch also nicht nicht wundern
und die rgbs gehen halt nur bis hier die leds ich habe jetzt noch einen zweiten noch zwei
zwei weiteres trips bestellt ein auf vorrat und einen den ich oben noch drumherum wickeln kann
dein ab isoliert champ ist heute gekommen sehr gut wer sich fragt was der ab isoliert
champ ist sekunde sekunde der ab isoliert champ ist das hier beste beste und wer sich jetzt fragt
mensch was mache ich damit die antworte ist ab isolieren und um das jetzt mal zu demonstrieren
hole ich mal kurz was zum ab isolieren da kommt der ab isoliert champ zum einsatz hier guckt da noch
isolierung drumherum und jetzt ab isoliert und da kann ganz schön schnell ganz schön viel ab
isolieren also meine kamera hat keinen bock sich zu fokussieren aber ihr könnt mir glauben das ist
ordentlich ab isoliert jetzt ja beste den brauche heute wahrscheinlich denke ich mal jetzt wo wir
gerade dabei sind ich kann euch mal kurz zeigen ich schnupp ich habe keine vorschau ich habe keine
vorschau ich muss mein tablet holen hoffentlich bin ich auf meinem tablet bei twitch eingeloggt
leute ich muss schnell mein tablet holen dass ich eine vorschau habe
jetzt aber was für ein tablet ich habe das ist ein ipad aber frag mich bitte nicht welches
irgendein also es ist nicht das pro oder das er wie heißt das pro gibt beides glaube so ganz
normales glaube also eine aktuelle normales ipad so twitch starten fack ich bin auch nicht
bei twitch eingeloggt ok jetzt wird problematisch kann ich das im browser irgendwie starten wo
blorz twitch ich brauche nämlich den vorschau vom chat und von dem stream weil ansonsten
ich will ich weiß ich will es im safari aufmachen ich weiß was ich machen will
ipad ich weiß was ich machen will ich möchte tatsächlich meinen stream
nee die twitch app geht nicht ohne log in warum man weiß es nicht ok so moment ich kann mir
die fucking auflösung ändern was meint ihr chat machen die die twitch webseite extra schlecht im
mobile browser ich glaube die machen die webseite extra kaputt im mobile browser dass man die app
verwendet anders kann ich mir das nicht erklären dass die seite auf dem desktop wunderbar funktioniert
und auf dem tablet was ja eigentlich auch ganz normaler halbwegs moderner browser ist außer
safari das sagt aber das ist immer noch modern genug die machen ist absichtlich schlecht dass
buttons nicht funktionieren und sowas die ist ab dies absichtlich verhunzt um es mal jetzt mal
aber effektiv zu sagen ja verhunzt richtig verunzt ich habe wo ich zivil ins gemacht habe ich
mache da muss meine vorschau hier mal stand wo ich zivil ins gemacht habe das habe ich habe ich
habe ich schon mal erzählt habe ich habe ich in der behindertenwerkstatt gemacht und jetzt kann
ich im quer format kein chat einblenden lull und da gab es eine die ist den ganzen tag rum
gerannt und hat gesagt sie wäre aggressiv die war nicht wirklich aggressiv die ist die ganze
nacht rumgelaufen ist aggressiv ist aggressiv ist aggressiv und die hat nicht gesagt aggressiv
sondern die hat immer gesagt avisiv und die meinte damit aggressiv aber die konnte das
nicht aussprechen die ganze nacht immer rumgelaufen gesagt aber sie aber sie aber sie hat mir jetzt
nicht wie ich da gerade drauf komme so gut jetzt muss ich das tablet hier hinten irgendwo
hinstellen die cycle story das habe ich noch nicht erzählt das kann ich recycle story sein
das kann das das ist leute das ist nicht recycle story das habe ich bestimmt noch nicht erzählt
oder na vielleicht habe ich doch schon mal weiß wer weiß so jetzt muss ich immer irgendwie gucken
dass ich mein tablet hier hinten platzieren so dass ich sehe und den chat sehen exzellent
so da so ungefähr ist jetzt das tablet oder chat alter wie weit hinten dran möchte bitte schön
twitch sein auf dem ipad im browser das ist ja ok pass mal auf 1 2 3 alter das ist ja das ist das
ist ja ewig weit hinten dran so 1 2 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 15 16 17 18 19 20 meine gute 20
sekunden sind die noch bescheuert oder was ich habe den chat auf dem pc aber ich habe hier
meinen basteltisch und der monitor ist dann quasi hier von da aus da ist der monitor da
ist das tablet hier steht das tablet jetzt in die richtung gucke ich und da ist da ist mein
chat preview und da ist der rechner den ich streame das funktioniert nicht ok ich zeige euch mal kurz
was wir machen du brauchst einen dritten ich bräuchte den dritten monitor am fenster hier
hinten so irgendwo also nur ganz kurz ich zeige euch jetzt mal schnell was wir was wir vor haben
den abisoliert shame habe ich ja schon gezeigt und mal das mal kurz weg also das mit meinem
weihnachtsbaum habe ich ja gerade gezeigt rumtour ja da muss ich gucken dass ich nicht so viel
liege das mit dem weihnachtsbaum habe ich ja gerade gezeigt und bei dem weihnachtsbaum ist
mir angefallen dass mein controller noch ein bisschen verbesserungswürdig ist also aktuell
ist es in esp 32 da drinnen und mit netzteil dran und leds dran also eigentlich relativ standard und
ich habe mir jetzt gedacht wäre es nicht cool wenn das ding einen an aus knopf hätte und wenn das
ding irgendwie die möglichkeit hätte helligkeit und effekte durchzuschalten am gerät selber ohne
dass ich über die app gehen muss da würden es auch nicht so technisch versierte benutzer checken und
dann habe ich mal geguckt was ich noch da habe an hardware und da bin ich jetzt so folgende idee
gekommen was wir machen können und zwar ich hoffe man sieht das jetzt ich habe hier so eine
wie mache ich das jetzt mit dem headset kabel dass ich mich da nicht halb selbst erwürge mit
bonkers so ich habe hier noch so eine ip 54 box da kann man wunderbar alles mögliche rein machen
sondern halbwegs wasserdichter wasserdicht so dann habe ich ein paar controller mal gucken
welche wir nehmen passen hier eigentlich alle ganz gut rein und habe ich mir gedacht wir können
einmal ein schalter nehmen an aus habe ich noch ein paar glaube noch drei oder vier stück an aus
schalter können wir dran machen und der an aus schalter ist ja in dem fall der der witz da dran
dass der nicht das komplette den kompletten controller und den kompletten led strip einen
ausschaltet strom sondern dass der dem controller den befehl gibt den led strip auszuschalten dass
der controller noch an bleibt dass man den über die app bedienen kann und wieder einschalten kann
also an ausknopf wäre cool und ich habe hier noch so ein paar dinger guck mal ist hier was das ist
hat jemand eine ahnung was das ist nein ist es nicht leider ist es das nicht wie akra die hat
genau genau es ist ein rotary encoder leider leider es ist kein wie heißt das eigentlich auf deutsch
potentiometer oder was wieder wie heißt das auf deutsch nein ist es nicht es ist leider nicht
weil also normalerweise gibt es ja diese dinger die einfach den widerstand höher und runter drehen
das ist das ist zum regel eigentlich ganz gut aber ich habe keinen ich habe ich habe nur einen
rotary encoder ich habe keine ahnung wie das auf deutsch heißt das ist so ähnlich nur dass das quasi
ein digitales signal ausgibt woran dann quasi die logik im controller erkennen muss ob hoch
gedreht wird oder runter es ist nicht so dass er irgendwie widerstand hoch und runter gedreht
wird das coole daran ist das hat ich versuche es mal zu zeigen du hast hier ich mache das mal ab
das ohne das ist der knopf du hast hier einmal dieses ding was du was zu drehen kannst das ist
dann da können wir zum beispiel sagen ok wir machen jetzt helligkeit hoch und runter und du
hast gleichermaßen ein knopf wo du funktionen mit umschalten kannst das heißt ich habe gedacht
beinchen ist abgebrochen das heißt man kann damit theoretisch solche sachen machen wie effekte
durch effekte durch schalten effekte durch schalten modus wechseln helligkeit hoch und
runter schalten modus wechseln effekte wisst ihr wie ich meine dass das das funkt das funktioniert von
der theorie her und die sache ist die led kann das standardmäßig nicht aber aber was ich gefunden
habe ist folgendes gibt es den hetzen account noch ja bis ende des jahres leute ausrufe zeichen
hetzner bis ende des jahres ist mein hetzner account noch lauffähig wenn ihr auch mal bei den großen
ein server hausten wollt die wissen was sie machen 20 euro startgutschein sichern hetzner
hetzner cloud könnt ihr euch schon drei monate lang kleinen server laufen lassen so was ich
gefunden habe ist hier unter user mods bei wled einen bin ich sicher ob das das da glaube ich
ja es gibt es gibt verschiedene verschiedene mods dafür es gibt zum beispiel ein
das ist ein komischer mod das bessere mod es gibt was wo man brightness und color ändern kann
den werden wir mal ausprobieren und irgendwas anderes das wollen wir nicht das da und damit
kann man wenn man damit wled gepatcht hat kann man dann auch solche dinger hier verwenden
mal gucken ob das funktioniert ich habe das noch nie ausprobiert also wled patchen was
heißt es ist nicht wirklich patchen du musst eine datei ändern und hoffen dass alles kompiliert
danach ist nicht so das schwierige ich würde sagen wir bauen erst mal ein bisschen wir machen
erst mal ein bisschen bastelstells und dann und dann machen wir die software geschichte weil ich
bin mir auch noch nicht ganz sicher wo ich einbauen soll ich habe zwei ich habe zwei boxen zur
auswahl entweder wir nehmen die große box hier die das was eigentlich sinniger wäre weil hier
passen quasi alle controller rein die ich rein machen will oder ich habe noch eine unbenutzte so
eine kleine box die kleine box ist zwar schöner weil die einfach stabiler ist aber hier ist
halt nicht viel platz drin also das höchste der gefühle was ich in diese kleine box reinkrieg
ist hier so einen d1 mini esp 32 dann ist aber halt auch voll mehr passt da leider nicht rein
deswegen nehme ich glaube ich die große box hier oben vielleicht kriegt man das hier guck
mal vielleicht kann man das leute ich hab eine idee vielleicht können wir ein bisschen platz machen
indem wir das hier irgendwie hier drunter drunter klemmen oder so ja guck mal da ist sogar platz aber
hier kriege ich doch keinen button rein ne ne das tut das zu fett das ding da kriege ich keinen
button rein und schon gar nicht schon gar nicht den button und so ein teil na doch das teil würde
ich rein kriegen das hängt ja hier oben dann so auf halb acht im deckel aber den button kriege
ich da nicht mehr rein ich glaube das ist einfach zu klein da ist nicht genug platz drin also was
meint ihr ich glaube also ich denke mal hier die etwas größere box ist auf jeden fall sinnvoller
zumal die kleine box auch komplett wasserdicht ist die kann ich für was anderes für was
anderes verwenden die vorschau ist so langsam so ultra langsam ach ja ich habe übrigens noch
was anderes am start guck mal hier schmeißt es mal kurz alles hier rein und das aber hier mal
weg ich habe noch was anderes am start und guck mal ich habe mir doch so ein elit festhalte ding
gekauft und heute probieren wir mal aus wie praktisch das teil ist da kann man theoretisch
dann so was machen kann man dann so kabel nehmen hier rein hier rein klemmen und dann kann man kann
man dann besser hier dran dritte hand gatschi bass oder also ich würde sagen wir nehmen das
ding ich stelle es mal hier neben hin so weil dann würde ich nämlich so machen wir machen
quasi hier unten den an und aus knopf und hier neben auf die andere seite sieht man das alles
gescheit ja also hier machen wir den an und aus knopf hier machen wir das ding zum drehen
hier in der mitte machen wir den stromanschluss dann haben wir die dinger hierfür aber den stromanschluss
ne das ist kein nf 52 das ist ein esp 266 und das ist ein esp 32 development board das andere
hier ist auch ein esp 32 gewesen wo ich gerade weiß wo ich den hingepfeffert habe
ja und da müssen wir wir müssen ja auch noch einen anschluss für die für die für die leds
man leds habe ich übrigens die hier am start sekunde nur zum testen habe ich die am start
so eine rolle mit ich bin mir gar nicht sicher welche das sind ehrlich gesagt ich glaube es
sind keine ws 2812 ich glaube es sind wie heißen die dinger sk 6512 oder so ich glaube das sind
welche die bin mir nicht sicher welche rolle ich rausgenommen habe vorhin aus dem schrank ist aber
zum testen auch ziemlich zweitrangig muss man einfach mal durchprobieren hat die maus wusste
denn die maus im bild überacht da ja das müsst ihr mir sagen das sehe ich immer so schlecht aus
dem augenwinkel also ich würde sagen wir bauen jetzt erst mal die box zusammen oder aber eigentlich
ist es bescheuert wir bauen nicht die box zusammen weil jetzt stellt euch mal vor wir bauen die box
zusammen und danach funktioniert der kram nicht wie gedacht auf der anderen seite scheiß drauf
wir machen das einfach ach ja und die als als anschlusskabel nehmen wir das hier für rgb das
hier in der mitte ist data das hier das rechts ist fünf voll und das links ist ground kann man
dann da direkt an die rgb an den an den led strip anschließen das kann man dann hier irgendwie
irgendwie durch machen was hat jemand gerade geschrieben mit kabel durchführung warte mal kurz
du meinst hier durch ne du meinst du meinst hier neben durch
das kann man mal ausprobieren ich habe noch so eine box zum testen wartet mal ihr guckt mal
ich habe hier noch eine box an der können wir ein bisschen rum basteln die ist die die hat
schon so was hier die hat schon loch ein ziemlich unschön ausgeschnittenes loch aber da kann ein
bisschen rum basteln das probieren probieren das doch mal aus ob das mit den schaltern funktionieren
testen wir das doch mal guck mal ich habe hier was ich habe was leute mein mein mein lieblings
mein lieblings borer aufsatz ich weiß es ist kein kegel borer ich habe letztens mal im video
gesagt es wäre ein kegel borer es ist kein kegel borer es ist ein stufen borer musste ich mich
belehren lassen ist er vom norma ne da ist von amazon gachi bass
ne da ist von amazon ich habe kein locher keine ahnung aber wir probieren es mal aus ich mache
mal kurz dieses komische das komische durchführung steil hier ab falls ich das ab falls ich das ab
kriege also probieren wir mal passen die frage ist passt das da überhaupt hin das leute ich glaube
guckt mal glaube das passt gar nicht richtig ich meine das loch kann ich natürlich größer machen
das ist nicht das problem aber guckt mal das wird ganz schön eng zu pepo fett aber wir probieren
es trotzdem aus einfach einfach volle pulle volle pulle durch hier probieren wir aus so gucken ob
das jetzt schon durchpasst oder nicht gachi bass fast fast doch das könnte tatsächlich und wisst
ihr was das coole an dem stufen borer ist guck mal das loch sieht aus wie als wäre es gemacht also
wie als wäre es so ausgeliefert worden das riecht nice ok muss noch ein bisschen größer
gucken wir mal ob es jetzt passt passt ooooh ooooh ooooh guck mal da guck mal da naja also ich
würde sagen eine eine stufe größer darf schon noch sein oder meinte ich soll es noch eine
größer machen oder ist es dann zu sehr gewackelt ich meine das ding hat hier noch so wiederhaken
sowas ich mach mal eine größer noch dachi bass steckt steckt fest leute das passt das passt
richtig gut das passt ich glaube das passt richtig gut hier aber hier machen wir das nach oben
leute ey wie angegossen guckt euch das mal an alter poggers guck mal hier wie wie angegossen
passt es und das ist das ist fest hier und es lässt sich auch poggers schalten das riecht
so passt der deckel noch drauf alter guck mal hier das sieht aus als wird es so ausgeliefert
ja da ist nice nice guck mal und das da hinten das zweck empfremden wir jetzt einfach für
dieses andere ding hier habe ich hier habe ich schon mal ohne ohne stufenbohrer versucht
was auszuschneiden das war nicht so von erfolg gekrönt wie man sieht ist schon ein bisschen
her ich glaube ich brauche kein kabelbinder weil guck mal das hat hier so wieder so wiederhaken
siehst du so wo habe ich denn jetzt den anderen krempel da ok ne das loch das loch ist dafür
definitiv zu pippo fett da machen wir noch ein anderes loch machen wir einfach direkt
daneben eins guck mal hier das ist ja auch gut da muss ich auch den deckel nicht kaputt
machen das ist viel geiler kein gachi bass am deckel und wisst ihr was das loch lasse
ich einfach drin da machen wir ich meine das ist doch auch im prinzip jetzt zumindest da
machen wir einfach hier die durch wisst ihr was ich mache einfach das teil da rein für
das kabel easy dann kann ich die box guck mal dann kann ich die box sogar recyceln nochmal
dann kann ich sogar die box recyceln der chat hat mich heute schon wieder auf gute ideen
gebracht muss ich sagen pock pock chat high IQ chat guck mal hier das sieht fast aus wie
gewollt nehmen wir das ja ich meine das sieht halt ein bisschen räudig aus jetzt man darf
sich halt nicht so genau angucken so und jetzt jetzt müssen wir nur noch den kollege da
irgendwie durch durch kriegen wo wollen wir den hin machen also lasst mal überlegen hier
muss ja der controller noch rein den können wir den controller können wir eigentlich
überall hinschmeißen achso und den stromanschluss brauchen wir auch noch wie ordnen wir das
denn jetzt am besten an also controller kann ich irgendwo am ende reinschmeißen meint ihr
es ist sinnvoll stromanschluss auf der seite wo würde den stromanschluss hin machen also
stromanschluss kommt dann später einfach so ein ganz normales so ganz normaler stecker
hier rein erst mal stufenbohrer bestellen leute ich sag euch beste einfach beste kauft
euch am besten ein dreier set mit unterschiedlichen größen
hinten ja wo ist hinten das ist dann vorne oder ist das vorne ich würde sagen das ist
vorne und das hier kommt auch vorne hin dann machen wir einfach dann wäre es natürlich
cool wenn led und so auch vorne egal mal gucken ob ich hier einen guten stromanschluss
ob ich dir vielleicht hier den stromanschluss besser durch kriege säck probieren wir das
gerade mal aus ich habe den doch wo habe ich denn hingelegt leute hier da hier sind hier
sind die dinger für den stromanschluss mal kurz den gachi bassbohrer weg machen seh
nix auf das ist da habe ich da habe ich ein bisschen zu hart gewütet hier hinten guck
mal da habe ich ein bisschen das war ein bisschen zu bisschen zu heftig ich meine ich könnte
ich könnte das noch irgendwie versuchen zu recyceln indem ich da so ein ring ring davor
mache in der hoffnung es rutscht jetzt nicht mehr durch ok das würde das würde gehen
aber mal ganz ehrlich schön schön ist was anderes an der stelle aber das aber da wäre
der strom besser aufgehoben da wäre der stromding aber besser aufgehoben auf jeden fall ok das
das überlege ich mir wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen ich baue jetzt den ich mache jetzt
das drehteil da noch dran und dann flaschen wir den erst mal und gucken ob das überhaupt
funktioniert bevor ich das jetzt irgendwie weiter baue will einfach mal gucken ob ich
den hier schön durch bekomme gucken wir mal gachi bass wieder am start oh what the fuck
habe ich das vorher nicht richtig festgemacht doch eigentlich schon ok war wohl nicht richtig
fest so wie kriege ich denn das da jetzt gescheit weg das passt nämlich prinzipiell schon kann
man einfach noch mal passt mal auf kamer davon innen irgendwie so noch mal ne das wird nichts
oder vielleicht soll ich das mit der immer das mit der zange ab wobei eigentlich ist es
ja egal das passt doch dadurch ja das passt eigentlich ganz gut machen wir den hier ab
ob das dadurch passt teppich mehr moment teppichmesser sehr gute idee der chat ist wirklich richtig
high iq heute ja guck dir mal wie gut das funst alter das sieht aus als hätte man das
so gekauft das sieht wirklich das sieht das sieht wirklich gut aus also für so gebasteltes
zeug das sieht wirklich aus wie so gekauft alter so und jetzt muss ich da noch das hütchen
drauf machen guckt mal ist das nicht nice liegt auf dem teppichmesser oh nein ist das
ist das nicht nice guck mal man hat hier das ist auch richtig fest man hier den knopf
zum ein und ausschalten hier hat man dann für helligkeit einmal klicken für effekte
klicken das ist cool chat chat massive brain die sache ist jetzt nur die also ganz fest
ist der kram noch nicht die sache ist plus die ich müsste mal gucken was ich da überhaupt
bestellt habe welche welche der beinchen was sind also sprich wisst ihr wie ich mein also
macht das kratz noch mal ab also welche sind davon was ich habe absolut keine ahnung striker
dankeschön für den zapp das multimeterzeit nee es ist nachgucken in der amazon bestellhistorie
und dann gucken ob ich hier eine datenplatte findet zeit also ich vermute mal das ist so
das hier das hier ist der schalter das hier ist wahrscheinlich der schalter das hier ist
wahrscheinlich einfach nur zum festhalten denke ich mal und das hier ist wahrscheinlich
wie auch immer gute frage keine ahnung ich muss mal ich gucke mal bei amazon in die bestellhistorie
amazon bei amazon müsste es aussprechen wie die coolen leute amazon oh Mist ähm ich bin
nicht bei amazon eingeloggt im anderen browser und auf dem tablet bin ich auch nicht bei
amazon eingeloggt moment wie kriege ich denn jetzt meine amazon bestellhistorie wait a
minute ich könnte ich könnte noch ein anderes tablet holen zum nachgucken ich muss mal schnell
noch ich muss mal schnell noch ein anderes anderes tablet holen
ich muss mal schnell noch ein anderes tablet holen
also ich habe nachgeguckt
es sind zwei ipads tatsächlich stripes hat recht ich habe nachgeguckt und zwar amazon
das ding nennt sich ec 11 rotary encoder natürlich treppe geflitzt jetzt ja so also so was da
müsste das sein gibt es da irgendwie ein datenblatt vielleicht gab es da eins in der
originale verpackung aber die originale verpackung habe ich doch schon das weiß ich wo die ist
die habe ich wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr so kampfkäfer danke für den zap was haben
man da zu bieten
das ist sehr teuer keine gut gär das ist schön und gut ich will wissen wie es funktioniert
ich komme hier aha aha okay
ich habe so was noch nie benutzt ich habe keine ahnung wie das funktioniert also das
ok dass das hier neben ist der switch das habe ich schon mal richtig erkannt das da
guckt hier die beiden das ist der switch woher erkenne ich jetzt da was hinten was vorne
ist wenn der switch links ist also sprich so müsste das dann quasi oben also unten der
links kommt an crown da oben kommt da dran ok das mit dem switch können wir jetzt gleich
mal ausprobieren das ist dann relativ easy und danach kommt dieser rotary encoder shit
ich habe keine ahnung wie das funktioniert ok dann brauchen wir jetzt wled auf gehts
wled patchen jetzt haben wled erstmal das shit repo klonen was wird hier fabriziert
wir bauen einen rgb ld controller mit ein ausschalter und so einem ich habe jetzt gelernt
wie das heißt mit einem dreh impulsgeber zum regeln der helligkeit und zum durchschalten
von effekten mal gucken also ich habe ja schon also dann der aufhänger ist das hier ich
habe heute mal weihnachtsbaum ausgestattet mit leds da ist so was ähnliches dran aber
ich habe mir gedacht es wäre schon cool wenn man das ein und ausschalten könnte ohne dass
man das netz aus der steckdose ziehen muss oder über die app halt beides am gerät und
über die app und wenn man so die einfachsten presets auch durchschalten könnte am gerät
selber richtig cool wäre das am besten also ich glaube nächsten weihnachten mache ich
dann die extended variante mit einem display oder so
links und rechts drehen ist dasselbe output
keine ahnung wie das funktioniert
nee das kann doch nicht sein
moment dann check ich nicht wie das funktionieren soll
ich schließe das ding jetzt einfach bei ahnung gucke ob es funktioniert scheiß drauf also
was wir brauchen ist folgendes wir müssen wled klonen ich schiebe das mal kurz da unten
hin das stört es nicht
so wir müssen wled klonen
stört mich überall
so und jetzt müssen wir diesen komischen das ist ja kein wirklicher patch das trifft
ja eigentlich gar nicht den hier müssen wir jetzt enable user mod rotary brightness color
guck mal auf dem github in dem repo punkt ja und jetzt
ach jenlo ja weihnachtsmodes stimmt das müssen wir noch machen ist ja erst ist ja noch lange
hin bis weihnachten
ok wie funktioniert das define user mod rotary encoder color in myconfig.h wo zum teufel ist
dann myconfig.h aha also myconfig wled myconfig nein nicht sample myconfig
muss ich die umbenennen oder wie funktioniert das
so welchen was haben wir denn hier gibt's log von heute
erstmal gucken ob ich so bilden kann wartet mal mal gucken ob ich ah moment ich muss platformer
io erst mal kurz installieren zum zum bauen ja ja wir trusten wir trusten allem kein ding
any trusters äh nein later nein später soll erst mal rufy konfiguriert wieder nee ich
hab rufy downgraded lull ich hatte kein bock das anzupassen so jetzt wird platformer io
installiert finished alles klar äh wo liegt denn das platformer io oh wo liegen denn wo
liegt denn der graben rum wo liegen hier die dinger denn zum aus ausführen rum bin ja
soll ich mal soll ich mal hier in meinem packen pass nee warte mal doppelpunkt ist es ne jo
habe ich irgendwas falsch gemacht achso nicht bin pio einfach nur bin lull ich schreibe
nicht in github nee das ist lokal ich hab das repo ich hab das repo äh geklont und
jetzt bin ich jetzt total bescheuert hä jetzt doch richtig ach nee home max lull ja einmal
mit profis äh jetzt funktioniert das auch so repos wled so gucken ob der das bauen
kann oh was macht er denn eigentlich er bildet node mcu v2 esp 32 und framework arduino ok
was auch immer ja dann bilde mal und wenn er bildet danach können wir custom konfig
anpassen erst mal gucken ob das prinzipiell überhaupt kompiliert bevor ich da jetzt großartige
sachen rumwürste ich kann mal kurz äh fragen gucken ja kann auch sein dass irgendwas in
der vr mit shortcuts nicht richtig funktioniert ja ich weiß das ist ein platform project haben
wir selbst im stream schon paar mal benutzt unter anderem wer erinnert sich noch an das
display wer war dabei wir hatten mal gegen den esp 32 bord mit display und mir ist nichts
besseres eingefallen wie dort die ganze zeit anzuzeigen kann sich doch irgend einer dran
erinnern sind die ganzen weeps wenn man sie braucht er wie es genau das das ist ein platformer
projekt das ist haupt das ist im prinzip eigentlich c++ only und anscheinend haut das
raus für esp 32 esp 2666 und arduino so schauen wir mal oh es es macht noch dinge
es macht dinger ei ei ei es hört ja gar nicht mehr auf
danke für die subs leute ich hab's gar nicht so auf dem schirm alles gehabt weil ich als
bisschen konzentratet war zeigt mal her kampf kevin subscription puzzle meister schreiker
95 eisfreak sam tation danke danke leute massive high IQ subscriptions mit er heute friends for
gaming danke für den sub da haben wir es jetzt bald mal hier vielleicht hätte ich
ein paar bild tagels ändern sollen dass da nicht so viel baut weil ich brauche sie nur
für den esp 32 wird alles händliche in die konsole gibt ja ich ich gebe mir müde nicht
so laut nicht so laut zu tippen im hintergrund eckermans der chat ist das kraut so ich habe
das kraut so erst an den chat der chat tippt das in wirklichkeit gerade in echtzeit sam
kano danke für den sub kub sofa 19 danke für den primes aber jetzt geht es ja richtig
los jetzt schlage bald bald kommt das gem train wieder mal gespannt was er alles baut also
wir müssen auf jeden fall ein paar plattformen zum kompilieren rausschmeißen weil ich brauche
das nicht für god und die welt zu bauen aber zumindest das kompilieren funktioniert das
macht mich zuversichtlich dass es mit dem patch auch gleich funktioniert das hat das
hat Alexa support sind ihr das das wled Alexa support hat ist mir neu mal ganz davon abgesehen
ist mir auch egal weil ich benutze keine Alexa ich benutze aber auch kein Cortana und kein
siri und kein google home und was gibt es da sonst noch so alles was fallen was fallen
euch noch für voice assistance ein gibt es dann mycroft gibt es noch da gibt es so ein
meme video wo das ding nicht funktioniert was gibt es denn sonst noch naja da gibt
es nicht wirklich das ist dieses home assistant ding was nicht wirklich gescheit ist aber
ansonsten was gibt es ich glaube das war es ne sam gibt sam das doch das samsung ding
ich sag nur rule 34 die haben sich an sam ganz schön abreagiert ne war das samsung
wer ist das mit sam ach keine ahnung das war samsung oder elf das ist irgendein linux
binary format elf ok mein elf linux was was heißt das das ist das executable and linking
format elf alles klar jetzt wissen wir bescheid ok der hat den kram jetzt gebaut also gucken
wir noch mal mein config also wisst ihr was mich wisst ihr was mich sehr stutzig macht
dass der hier zwischenzeitlich was geschrieben hat er nicht eben was geschrieben von guck
mal hier myconfig.h hä was ist das für ein shit ok also wenn auch nicht mal kommandozeilen
suchding funktioniert dann weiß ich anders also myconfig.h so und was soll ich da jetzt
machen define nee sag was das da define usermod rotary encoder brightness ok man muss ja irgendwelche
pins setzen open usermod settings ok das ist das ist dann web interface das ist das web
interface da wo man das später machen muss denke mal ok so kann ich hier in dieser config
auch heute ich will eigentlich nur einen esp 32 bauen den ganzen restlichen kram brauche
ich nicht hier esp 32 def reicht so run mal gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert wahrscheinlich
gleich sundagsfehler crash broken ah yes exquisite exquisite so da ist unsere firmware angeblich
haben wir jetzt support für rotary encoder brightness and color jetzt müssen wir das
ding mal flaschen auf den guten hier auf den da flashchamp leute flashchamp haben wir esp
tool drauf esp tool ist am start wled wiki wie war das noch mal esp tool binary ahja
ist gemoved die haben jetzt ein eigenes wiki ich verstehe gar nichts wenn du was wissen
willst kannst du fragen aber das ist so ein bisschen so wie wenn dich der lehrer eine
stunde voll gelabert hat und du dann sagst ich habe keine ahnung der lehrer sagt ja was
genau nicht und dann sagst du alles das funktioniert hier flashchamp so wo liegt das binary rum
bild output klingt gut bild output release wled 013 0 b6 esp 32 um 19 uhr 45 ja das kommt
hin exzellent gut ich stöpsel mal kurz den controller dran und dann flaschen wir den
flashchamp ich hoffe da geht den usb kabel geht net ok blub blub blub blub vor allem
ja please das ist das richtige ob das muss sein ok esp tool flash output nee wenn man
das bild output wled nee release wled 013 b6 esp 32 bin bamm auf gehts der flashchamp
läuft gleich ist es geprägt jetzt brauche ich mein tablet gleich jetzt brauche ich gleich
mein tablet um zu gucken ob dann ein exis point aufgeht oder nicht die kamera noch exis
point champ erst mal erst mal in ruhe flaschen lassen und dann brauche ich dann brauche
ich das password leute das password für den für den wir müssen wir müssen den exis point
erst noch anschließen leute da hinten ist er der heimliche star eines jeden bastel streams
wo ist er hier small exis point ist am start der muss ran der muss ran so gut und jetzt
dass der switch noch angeschlossen werden ich hoffe das hier ist der richtige stecker
für den switch sonst macht es gleich funktioniert ok ah ok der exis point hängt aus oh gott
das was habe ich hier was habe ich hier gebastelt der exis point der braucht ja noch strom der
raspberry pi ist ja heute gar nicht angeschlossen moment strom für den exis point noch jetzt
ich weiß nicht ob man sieht aber die led ist an der muss mal aus dem bild raus jetzt weil
wir brauchen hier gleich platz mein log 4j was ist denn da los log 4j ich hab heute nur
ganz kurz bei heise was gelesen dass es irgendwie huge massive sicherheitslücken gibt in java
ich habe das null verfolgt ok also schauen wir mal wifi
sollte das flaschen hat nicht funktioniert
kann das sein dass ich diesen esp 32 noch nie im einsatz hatte und ich deswegen erst
mal erase aber wie ging das noch mal erase so
dass ich quasi esp tool erase flash dass ich noch einen bootloader brauche zero day
liquid lock for you shell das ist schlecht moment hier if esp 32 ist nur you will need
to flash bootloader first ok dann flaschen wir erst den bootloader es kann sein dass
ich den bootloader gar nicht drauf hab esp 32 spinn bootloader gib ihm ok bootloader
flaschen jetzt den bootloader yep yep flash download download ja download esp 32 bootloader
bin gib ihm jawoll und jetzt flash noch mal esp so und jetzt hoffe ich dass es funktioniert
wenn nicht ist vielleicht der esp kaputt oder so oder es hat nicht funktioniert weil
ich da gemacht habe ok da gucke ich mir log von j security ich hab keine ahnung davon
ich hab wie gesagt so gut wie nie was mit java gemacht aber je nachdem wie verbreitet
das ist das standard library oder ist das irgendeine sagen wir mal fast schon standard
library verbreitete logging library oder apple twitter amazon tausende andere die sind
einfach der erste angriff verlaufen bereits ach bin ich froh dass ich urlaub habe wir
haben viel java auf der arbeit über eine kritsche 0 der sich als lock for you shell
ok leute ich bekomme kein access point ich bekomme kein access point für wled ah jetzt
ist er da der wled access point ist da leute bäm guckt mal hier ich zeige euch dass es
funktioniert bäm wled am start mit mit custom patch ok wifi settings ich connecte mich
mal zum access point kann ich euch jetzt leider nicht zeigen so brauche ich das password ich
habe eine datei die sich flasch auf zitz rotz zitz alter das kann ich auch flasch schorz
sie ritz ich kann mal ich ich habe flasch geschrieben und dann habe ich irgendwelche
random buchstaben hinten dran gemacht an die datei weil es schon eine datei gab die
flasch heißt und jetzt heißt die datei flasch schorz zitz rotz alles klar jetzt weisen wir
bescheid so muss das sein ok nennswork password ratet mal wie das password ist kommt ihr nie
drauf für den test access point aber 123 kommt drin vor ja gary das ist gar nicht so weit
weg davon gar nicht so weit weg davon ok safe und connect bäm jetzt schauen wir mal wir
gehen jetzt mal auf den access point und schauen ob da sich was eine ip geholt hat mikrotik
access point das müsste der sein was ist denn admin aha guck mal da das ist er wled pogchamp
bäm ach nee root add ja so bäm wled da sind wir da sind wir so und da sollte es jetzt
wo hat er gesagt in der config user mods user mit rot eng brightness alles klar da wissen
wir bescheid wir nähern unserer sache ok wir brauchen jetzt verschiedene pin settings esp
32 note mcu pin out mal gucken welchen pin wir nehmen bei hacker news gibt infos ja guck
ich dann klein wir nehmen jetzt einfach pin ich das ist aber nicht das nicht das richtige
auch nicht das richtige alles müll das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht ja das kommt noch am
ehesten hin wir nehmen einfach pin 14 für den button und 12 und 13 für die anderen
das liegt schön nebeneinander das brauchen wir für die leds das brauche für strom ok
schauen wir mal also pin fade amount was auch immer was für pins muss ich denn da was
setze ich denn da eigentlich jetzt für pins was muss ich denn was muss ich denn da jetzt
machen ist pin a on your rotor ist pin b on your rotor ist the button on your ah ok ok
ok ok dann machen wir das dann machen wir das anders pin 0 also also moment amazon ok mal
gucken ob das jetzt ob das jetzt irgendwie passt was ich mache also pin 14 ist das da
pin 14 ist das the crown ok out b hier 14 mal nehmen wir ne gibt's aber diese pin nummerierung
ich suche weil fast nebeneinander ist mal mal 12 ja 14 und 12 14 und 12 oh 12 ist schon
belegt monkaS warum ist 12 schon belegt was ist denn noch 15 frei wo ist denn 15 wo ist
15 15 auf der anderen seite alter die pin benamung sind einfach komplett wir ok wie
sieht es mit mit 13 aus 13 ist auch 13 und 14 13 und 14 und was haben wir als nächstes
15 ist auf der anderen seite 13 14 ne ach ne 12 hat er gesagt ne 15 aber 15 ist auf der
anderen seite 15 15 ist hier drüben ja meinetwegen dann halt da drüben ist auch scheiß drauf
ok das probieren wir mal das schließen wir jetzt an das schließen wir jetzt mal an und
gucken ob das funktioniert wir sollten ja dann zumindest im web interface sehen noch
mal save wir sollten dann zumindest im web interface sehen dass was passiert hoffe ich
mal ich bin mal gespannt ob das funst ok nice gg eats also hier zum glück zum glück sind
die dinge ordentlich beschriftet was pins angeht guck mal da findet man wenigstens was
haben wir jetzt gesagt 13 14 ne 12 12 13 14 haben wir gesagt ok so oh jetzt ich sollte
das nicht so auf die erde pfeffern pfeffer jam so und jetzt brauchen wir das hier guck
mal mitte war ground und das ist dann irgendwie was auch immer haben wir noch paar kabels
boar kann man das direkt hier rein stecken ah mist meinte meinte das geht man zum testen
wäre das ja schon echt gut näh das funktioniert das ist ja crap das funktioniert richtig mann
zum testen wäre das natürlich schon praktisch wenn das einfach au alter guckt euch das mal
an zählte schon unter selbstverletzung wäre ich jetzt gebannt
hat es drehbordes raus wie kriege ich denn das da jetzt gescheit dran ich meine ich
könnte ich könnte dran löten ich löte das einfach dran ok das heißt von der idee her
gehe mal weg hier zack von der idee her folgendermaßen hier also 13 alter was ist wo ist das jetzt
ja näh 12 13 ok 12 ich bin ich bin extrem verwirrt die crown auch noch alles ja praktisch
guck mal leute ground ist genau zwischen 12 und 13 das ist doch wunderbar ground ist das
hier in der mitte in dem fall ich brauche noch zwei solcher kabels und ich weiß nicht
ob ich hier welche habe näh das sind normale ich habe definitiv noch welche aber ich weiß
grad nicht wo das mal kurz hier unten in die box gucken hab ich da vielleicht noch was
direkt hier drinnen ich habe jede menge ich habe jede menge kabels aber die brauchen wir
ja nicht was haben wir hier aha das ist nix das ist nix haben wir hier vielleicht irgendwas
gescheits ich werde doch von dieser sorte jumper kabel noch ein bisschen was haben also
ich habe bestimmt welche aber ich weiß halt grad nicht wo na geil ok das muss ich auf
jeden fall vom erdboden auf ihm habt ihr euch schon mal eine frage chat habt ihr euch schon
mal so einen jumper kabel in die verse aus versehen gesteckt weil so was auf dem fußboden
lag wahrscheinlich nicht deswegen werde ich euch jetzt mal beschreiben wie das ist wenn
man das macht aus versehen die verse da ist ja die haut ein bisschen dicker und wenn man
das auf dem teppichboden hat und dann quasi mit dem fuß über den teppichboden fährt
dann hört ihr auf auf einmal dass es dann so quasi macht so und das ist die haut die
an eurer verse reißt wenn das jumper kabel sich dann da rein steckt das will man nicht
glaubt es mir das ist äußerst schmerzhaft ich hab keine jumper kabel mehr ich hab auf
jeden fall welche aber ich weiß nicht wo das sind alles guck mal ich hab jede menge
davon das sind alles die normalen die bringen mir in dem fall gar wisst ihr was wir machen
wir sind jetzt wir sind jetzt richtig richtig big brain wir nehmen jetzt einfach davon
welche so und wir nehmen den ab isoliert champ knipsen das teil ab und ab isolieren
uns da oben das stück und das löten wir jetzt dran fertig aus so machen wir das jetzt kein
bock drei stunden zu suchen so das hier mal weg lötkolben anmachen
manchmal muss man manchmal muss man manchmal muss man etwas erfinderisch werden so dann
machen wir das mal hier rein und jetzt eine runde lötschamp mal ein bisschen müll einsammeln
ach komm das gibt heute noch mehr müll hat keinen sinn so wir müssen jetzt also wenn
ich das richtig wenn ich das richtig checken was da bei amazon steht ist das folgendermaßen
bis da an diese drei in der mitte ground das hab ich kapiert und dann ansonsten a und b
und das muss an die richtigen pins dran gut dann leute ich bin übrigens richtig entfans
guck mal ich hab sogar ne lupe mittlerweile für sowas leider ist die ein bisschen schlecht
platziert dass ich bis dahinten nicht hinkomme in meinem aufnahme start up aber dann seh
ich sogar besser was hast du keine krimz zange nee
so wo haben wir es denn hier gut hier schön schönen schönen schönen dämpfer einatmen
leute chat haut rein gibts euch wir machen das mal anders ich glaub wir machen die erste
mal eine runde jetzt ein bisschen was dran und dann bevor wir die kabels dran machen
machen wir hier mal ein bisschen ich guck jetzt mal von oben durch das problem ist dass
genau da wo ich normalerweise mein gesicht habe ist das ergato key light ring light was
ziemlich sagt ok dann wollen wir das mal dran machen soll das in der mitte das in der mitte
ist ground ok so viel habe ich das ist halt alles ziemlich kleines gefuddelt das ist
das ist für irgendwelche breadboards gedacht oder so aber nicht zum direkt ranlöten gut
next so ein kabels brauchen wir noch nächste kabel champ next loud 23 mal testen oh nee
next loud reg ich mich immer nur auf next loud reg ich mich nur auf ok haben wirs
ergeblich funktioniert das jetzt so also wenn ich das richtig gemacht habe es hält
nicht richtig also es hält schon aber es ist das lutz ist nicht komplett durch das
was wir nochmal anders machen so jetzt aber ist richtig dumm wenn man da wo man sein kopf
eigentlich hin hält wenn dort das ring light ist hast du da aus Versehen eine brücke gelötet
da brückt sich nix keine brücke wenn der scheiß mal sich blies scharf stellt da ist
keine brücke so also von der idee her haben wir gesagt der da auf ground der da auf ground
der da auf 12 und der da auf 13 und das soll jetzt funktionieren oder was ich hab da so
meine zweifel dass das jetzt klappt aber mein probieren geht über studierende testen wir
mal bräuchte mal ein usb kabel testen wir mal meint ihr das geht leute meint ihr jetzt
es funktioniert schauen wir mal vor allem woran sehe ich ob es funktioniert ist die eigentliche
frage gut nur das feinste werkzeug ja gutes werkzeug ist die halbe miete jedoch so also
nochmal kurz kontrollieren ob ich jetzt auch alles richtig angeschlossen habe user mods
13 14 15 15 ist das switch den habe ich nicht angeschlossen 13 14 habe ich 13 14 es ist
falsch was ich angeschlossen schon wieder es ist schon wieder falsch ich hab schon verkehrt
angeschlossen nee doch was ist das eigentlich jetzt mal als ab welcher china chineser hat
sich diese nummerierung ausgedacht ich meine 13 ground 12 14 27 what the fuck ich hab das
auf 12 stecken und ich muss es eigentlich auf 14 stecken so so muss es sein hier guckt
so da muss einmal loch sein in der mitte nee 12 ist aus irgendwelchen gründen schon anderweitig
belegt keine ahnung ok und jetzt 13 14 habe ich jetzt habe ich jetzt 13 14 ich bin echt
verwirrt 13 14 habe ich ja 13 12 ist frei und 14 ok jetzt drehen wir mal dran und gucken
was passiert was sollte denn passieren wenn ich da dran drehe ey leute die brightness guckt
mal oben rechts aber die backen bisschen guck mal man darf nicht so schnell drehen man darf
nicht so schnell drehen das ist das ist aber ziemlich erlaubt wenn ich schnell drehe das
blickt vielleicht auch nicht dran greife guck mal wenn ich schnell drehe plus ist kein problem
aber runter darf ich nur langsam drehen runter darf ich nur langsam drehen
aber hoch darf ich schnell drehen naja oder auch nicht
aber prinzipiell funktioniert das erstaunlich gut hätte ich nicht gedacht es ist ziemlich
gut das funktioniert einfach so und jetzt der switch jetzt der switch switch muss auf
seck round und gpio ja hoffentlich hat er den pull up angemacht hier drin weil sonst
wird das ja so nix ok auf 15 nee wir haben wir das jetzt eingestellt 15 15 ist das switch
ok wo ist gpio 15 überhaupt gpio 15 ist da unten das erwartet man natürlich auch dass
gpio 15 da ist hier ist 13 12 14 das heißt 15 muss dann da drüben sein ist ja logisch
obvius ja obvius weiß auch nicht wie man da nicht drauf kommen kann ok dann löten wir
da jetzt noch mal zwei kabels dran ein ground brauchen wir noch ground hat das ding zum
Glück ein paar so viele crown pins hat das gar nicht da hinten hat es noch ein crown
pin und da hat es noch ein crown pin ich meine ich mach zwar die schönen jumper kabels
jetzt kaputt aber mann was solls 15 ja und crown brauchen wir noch das der abisoliert
champ ist wieder am am werk und crown brauchen wir noch für den switch das heißt das stecken
wir schon mal hier auf den übrig gebliebenen ground port da einmal ground und dann muss
der hier der hier muss auf 15 und 15 ist hier unten das gelbe ist 15 sagt mal eigentlich
ist es doch egal wie rum oder ich meine ob ich jetzt hier crown und da switch mache
oder da crown und da switch ist doch eigentlich wurscht oder sehe ich das falsch ich meine
das ist ein schalter dazwischen und wenn er geschaltet ist gehts wirds low eigentlich
ist doch egal wie rum also wir machens mal so wie die das dahin gemalt haben schadet ja
nix und die haben das so gemacht hier so das heißt es ist jetzt spiegelverkehrt ich mach
mal in groß das ist in spiegel verkehrt das heißt oben ist jetzt ground gucken wir mal
das ist jetzt mal hier unten in der hoffnung ich seh da aber das ist halt wirklich ziemlich
kacke wenn ich nix sehe sieht man ganz gut fast so so dann machen wir das mal dran ground
ist oben gut ground ist dran andere ist auch dran alles klar ne ne nicht gelb ist ground
gelb ist 15 so schauen wir mal ob es jetzt funktioniert leute auf gehts wo ist das kabel
tropf traditionelle
everyone
ich
oh
Aber das ist schlecht wenn das nicht leute wenn es nicht booted ist meistens kein gutes zeichen das weiß ich aus eigener erfahrung
alle momentan tps. Keck wait
Firefox
So geht es aber nicht
Also geht das drehen noch
Ja das funktioniert noch
So und jetzt was was passiert denn jetzt mit dem knopf
Knopf was was genau
Oh, guck mal es geht leute
Jetzt werden die farben durchgeswitcht guck mal einmal drücken einmal drücken brightness
drücken modus wechseln farbe switchen
Funktioniert
Das ist nice
Okay, das hat jetzt deutlich einfacher funktioniert als ich mir das vorgestellt habe wenn ich ehrlich bin
So machen wir noch mal hier
Klicken und jetzt brightness hoch
Sehr sehr pock massive pock massive
Pock massive pock massive
Warum ist das so dunkel
Keine ahnung aber es funktioniert es funktioniert es ist unglaublich das ist aber easy
Okay, das ist das war jetzt relativ einfach ich bin fast geneigt ich bin fast geneigt das einfach so zu lassen
So jetzt brauchen wir unseren button den da
bouton
Clips Clips Clips button
Wo machen wir den dran
Wir sehen dann so die standard die standard buttons dazu aus zeigt mal her
LED preferences
Standard button ist gpio 0 ob das so eine gute idee ist war gpio 0 nicht bei einem
ESP 32 Spezial Bedeutung
Gpio 0 war doch zum flaschen oder? Nee der machen wir auf jeden fall nicht an gpio 0
Den machen wir an was für einen gpio haben wir dann hier noch schönes freie
Also die hier haben wir jetzt belegt also wir haben jetzt 15 belegt
Und 12 13 oder sowas
Nehmen wir doch einfach den daneben
Ne der war schon belegt warum was ist nicht 12 war belegt 12 war belegt
Ach für relay gpio das ist weg minus eins
Und dann nehmen wir für unseren button doch jetzt einfach mal
So das ist ein switch
Ach wegen dem dark reader ist so dunkel so gpio 12 für den switch safe
Bec
Champ
Du du du du du du
Die sie sehen wie wir können das jetzt am besten testen ob der ob der switch funktioniert
Die testen wir des jetzt am besten ob der switch funktioniert
Müssen wir jetzt nochmal dran löten alle ich mache mir, so viele jumper kabeln kaputt ich habe ich habe tausende davon noch aber
Sollte, mal, die anderen suchen was wird gebastelort wir basteln einen
eine RGB-LED-Steuerung, aber diesmal advanceder, mit einem Ausschalter und einem Drehimpulsgeber,
habe ich mir sagen lassen, dass das hier so heißt, für Helligkeit und Farben durchswitchen.
Gut, das heißt, wir brauchen, einmal für den Switch, Leute, ich hätte, ah nee, ich
habe, ich bin doch blöd, ich kann das Kabel doch doppelt verwenden, guck mal, ich bin
richtig, ich bin richtig low IQ, ich hätte das Kabel in der Mitte durchschneiden sollen
und einfach doppelt verwenden.
Richtig low IQ, das ist so zu machen, dich braucht noch gar nicht so lange Kabel, 5-Head,
nee, eher 3-Head, ja dann machen wir das jetzt so, dann machen wir das jetzt so, machen wir
das zumindest mit dem hier so, zack, Mitte durchschneiden, abisolieren, oh, wo habe ich
ihn, wo habe ich ihn, da ist er, zack, ich hätte übrigens den Schalter vielleicht mal,
ah, geh raus, Schalter, oh, habt ihr den fliegen gesehen, hallo Schalter, Schalter, Schalter,
ha ha, gut, passt das hier rein, hey, ey guck mal, es hält, alles klar, Lootstation muss
haben wir eine runde jetzt sehe ich wieder nix muss das so umdrehen seht ihr noch was
jetzt haben wir hier das schalter dran
die joshi musik dazu alter wie heiß es denn das das wird ja gar nicht kalt man
jetzt wird es kalt das habe ich ein bisschen zu heiß gemacht das ding das hat ja fünf
stunden gebraucht bis es kalt geworden ist
schalter ist abgehoben ja ok hält flashbacks als lehrer pull up pull down ich erklären konnte
aber schlecht wenn der lehrer das nicht erklären kann deswegen ist er ja lehrer ich könnte das
natürlich ohne probleme erklären aber ich bin ja zum glück nicht der lehrer
gut ich meine im prinzip ist es tatsächlich relativ einfach weiß bloß nicht wie ich den
worte fassen soll pull up pull down bei dem einen machst du ein resistor zwischen quasi
3,3 volt und dem du machst auf der einen seite den gp out ran auf der anderen seite machst du
irgendwie keine ahnung 10k widerstand dran dann machst du wie sie sieht ran dass das ding quasi
standardmäßig high ist und bei einem pull down machst du es umgedreht dass es standardmäßig
low ist oder keine ahnung null elektro stellts so schalter ist am start jetzt den kann man
angreifen ist nicht mega heiß so also wie schalten wir das jetzt also wo machen wir das jetzt ran
chat wisst ihr noch was ich gesagt habe welcher welcher pin 12 voll dich nehmen 12 für den
schalter habe ich gesagt oder 12 12 ist der hier 12 und dann einmal auf ground noch fack
habe ich noch ground einmal ground noch please round ground da ist noch ein ground habe ich
glück dass das der controller so viele anschlüsse hat er ok so alles dran alles drin
ja ja genau das bein streich es weiß ich das ist für den default wert das ist weil du weil
du nicht willst dass das ding floated was bei einem sp 32 nicht sein muss weil der hat interne pull
ab und pull down resistors hast du erfahrung mit wifi 6 kommt drauf an was du wissen willst genau
so
dann testen wir mal wie es geht ob es geht
hallo warum ist usb immer falsch rum ja also die nord des nord mcu board hat pull
ab und pull down aber ich glaube nicht alles auf jedem pin da muss man gucken ich glaube manche
pins gibt es nur eins von beiden und manche pins glaube ich auch gar nicht weil die für
irgendwelche standardsachen gebraucht werden gp 0 und sowas so ich schalte jetzt mal den schalter
und guck mal was passiert nichts das habe ich mir gedacht weil es auch noch eingestellt also led
preferences switch gpio 12 das ist schon mal richtig so dann muss man wenn ich das richtig
nur time und macros und dann muss ich sagen button 0 soll preset 1 also wenn ich den button einschalte
also von an auf ausschalten soll es preset 1 sein von von off auf on preset 2 save back
jetzt müssen wir presets speichern also presets haben ja zack preset create preset keine ahnung
und save presets create off ne das stimmt nicht was ich hier mache lull sack off presets create off 2
save ok ja das funktioniert prinzipiell letztens die frage funktioniert das auch wenn ich den
knopf drücke chat jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt
nee es wäre auch zu einfach gewesen hätte das einfach funktioniert
nee
nix prediction ich habe es ausprobiert das funktioniert nicht
habe ich irgendwas mit der config falsch gemacht wir machen jetzt mal was leute wir
testen mal was ob es vielleicht an dem button liegt wir testen mal was ob es vielleicht an
dem button liegt ich mache den button mal weg und wir nehmen den switch wir nehmen mal den
switch von dem hier und gucken ob es daran liegt das gelbe kommt von 15 runter auf 12 das funst
habt ihr es gesehen mit mit dem button funst das mit dem anderen button funktioniert aus
irgendwelchen gründen nicht vielleicht liegt es am ground ok machen wir den hier mal ab der
benutzt den ground hier hinten den benutzen wir jetzt auch pio 12 das liegt am crown pin den darf
ich nicht dafür verwenden aus gründen Leute guckt mal funst zack an zack aus progas schaut
hier guckt euch guckt euch hier seht ihr power off und on an hier zack an zack aus funst aus
irgendwelchen gründen klappt der crown pin über den anderen nicht warum nicht weiß ich nicht
wahrscheinlich weil es der crown für 5 volt ist wobei ground ist eigentlich ground soll es doch
kein unterschied machen nee an dem crown pin funktioniert einfach nicht der crown pin ist
einfach ausgeleihert as fuck nee aber das funktioniert nicht der funst nicht warum auch
immer aber moment jetzt bin ich ja auch blöd gewesen warte mal falscher ich habe gerade
ground auf ground gesteckt das kann er nicht funktionieren so gpio 12 das ist geht er noch
ja geht noch
muss ich aufpassen dass es nicht ausgesehen auf 5 volt stecke das war ziemlich ein ziemlicher
pains jam nee der funst einfach nicht ok was ja nicht schlimm ist ich habe ja genug ground pins
ok also klappt an sich alles das heißt wir können es jetzt mal in die box einbauen gucken
wir mal gucken wir mal wie das in der box funst also die box button wie machen wir das jetzt am
besten ich brauche einmal mehr ground als ich habe das ist doof ich kann ich kann den ground
einfach mit an den stromanschluss dran löten dürfte nicht das einfachste sein ja oder was
meint ihr das ist wahrscheinlich die simpelste variante wenn ich die kraut da brauche ich die
kraut pins hier drauf gar nicht ich nehme einfach die kraut pins direkt am stromanschluss also
also das heißt wir wir machen jetzt erst mal
ja da funst eh nicht stromanschluss braucht ja schon einen ground hier drauf nee das klappt
nicht ok das lassen wir mal angeschlossen also jetzt muss ich mal kurz überlegen das kommt da
rein so passt wunderbar an aus das da muss ich mal gucken wie wir das machen das lasse
ich auf jeden fall hier drauf weil sonst finde ich nachher die richtigen pins nicht mehr das
weiß ich jetzt schon wir machen jetzt erst mal den stromanschluss dran leute ich glaube ich
missbrauche einfach wirklich dieses dieses das das nicht so nicht so schön gekatterte loch
dafür vielleicht kann ich das geht das hier passt das oh nice guck mal leute das passt da
kann ich das verstecken kann ich das damit verstecken und menschen kurz was suchen ich
habe doch irgendwo so komische größere pippo fett dinger nee das passt das geht nicht
das passt das passt leider nicht dadurch das ist ja doof
nicht so schön rausgekattert ja was ich nicht verstehe guck mal hier drehen die
dinger sich ohne probleme durch der hier mag nicht den interessiert das nicht hier guck
das der funst nicht was echt blöd ist weil den da den könnte ich wunderbar den könnte
ich wunderbar hier drauf setzen guck mal das würde fast das würde fast nicht auffallen
wenn da dieses ding drauf wäre fast vielleicht braucht es einfach nur ein bisschen nachhilfe
dass es funktioniert bisschen bisschen mehr kraft wartet mal ich brauche noch mal andere andere
zange
guck mal ich habe doch hier so ein drauf das muss doch moment leute guck mal das muss
funktionieren hier habe ich doch auch so ein drauf seht ihr das aber der ist wahrscheinlich
nicht weit drauf der steckt da wahrscheinlich nur so ein bisschen so ein bisschen drauf
wie es gerade passt und ich will ihn ja eigentlich vorne da ist es ich sehe nicht mehr ok wir
probieren mal aus ob man ein bisschen mit ein bisschen mehr kraft ob man das mit ein
bisschen mehr kraft hinbekommt schauen wir mal
ja bisschen mehr kraft funktioniert überhaupt kein ding
das ist zwar ein bisschen ist zwar nicht so big brain aber es funktioniert
ok einfach alles heiß klebern ja ich will ja das loch verstecken leute ich will ich
will das loch verstecken guck mal guck mal jetzt sieht man das loch kaum oder guck mal
das ist doch fast fast fast zu ich habe das fall ich habe das falsch rum drauf ich muss
noch mal abmachen fast ich hoffe das funktioniert jetzt noch
guck mal das das geht das geht das geht so das ist in ordnung und jetzt hier einfach
mit schmugges ja passt nice das machen wir jetzt so vorher löten wir den kram aber
noch dran und zwar brauchen ein kabel für plus und eins für minus und dafür nehmen
wir mal jetzt davon welche von denen hier eigentlich ganz gern für nehmen wir da mal
was kurzes so und machen wir mal eins genauso lang ab da wunderbar moin mr lolf ich kann
nachher wenn ihr wollt ich kann auch eine runde heißkleber reinschmeißen wenn es sein muss
so also wir müssen jetzt den stromanschluss da mal fest fest lötsch lötschdelsen ähm
schauen wir mal kriegen wir das da rein aber gerade so passt das wunderbar lötschkollmann
holen und erstmal richtig viel rauf klatschen bäm bäm bäm erst mal ordentliche portion
hier jawoll gib ihm und hier auch wird warm ordentliche portion erst mal draufgeklext
so warte mal außen ist außen ist minus hier mit ist plus gut gut sehr schön normalerweise
könnte man halt so einen schrumpf schlauch drüber machen oder so aber aber wir sind
man nicht so wer braucht schrumpf schläuche kann die kamera bitte mal hier ordentlich
scharf stellen was ist hier los was soll das ja so ist es besser zu viel als zu wenig lötschen
zu verwenden na ja man muss es nicht total übertreiben aber in der regel zieht sich
das ja auch immer immer ganz gut dann überall rein also es ist es ist tatsächlich sogar
finde ich relativ schwierig zu viel zu nehmen also wenn natürlich ganz komplett zu kleistern
aber ja also meistens ist es nicht zu viel so dann den machen wir anders den machen wir
anders rum immer nämlich nicht ganz sicher wie rum ich den hatte so rum dann nehmen wir
hier durch dann legen die nämlich auf unterschiedlichen seiten so ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es richtig
fest ist mal ausprobieren ja ich denke schon dass es ordentlich fest ist ja guck mal ich
glaube das ist ganz gut geworden wenn der scheiß mal hier das passt schon das ist ordentlich
das was da verdampft ist glaube ich am ehesten noch das flussmittel oder ich bin es eigentlich
eine gute frage wahrscheinlich wird ein bisschen ein bisschen zinn und blei auch noch in dem
dampftrennen sein ok so machen wir das mal aus so dann hier kabels durch und jetzt fest
machen und hoffen das funktioniert ja passt ich muss sagen das funktioniert
besser als ich mir das gedacht habe und das ist fest kann es nicht sagen das ist echt
ordnung eigentlich ziemlicher pochchamp so das heißt jetzt auch eigentlich ist alles
so wie es sein muss wir müssen jetzt bloß noch die ganzen geschichten an den controller
anschließen und dann final test ob alles funktioniert sind die gehäuse selbst gut nein das sind
fertiges gehäuse das ist fertiges ip 54 gehäuse also ip 54 ist was spritzwasser geschützt
und staub geschützt oder so das muss dann hier später noch dran muss ich mal kurz überlegen
wir müssen ha ha leute da muss ja noch rgb da müssen auch die rgb dinger gleich dran
wo habe ich denn mein anschluss für die rgb dinger hin da da muss so ein rgb muss ja
da noch dran habe ich ja ganz vergessen dass du zu testen können ob es funktioniert
dann mache ich einfach mal kein deckel drauf zum ausprobieren ähm sekunde sekunde wie
machen wir das denn jetzt am besten so das da plus das da mitte data das da ground löte
ich das jetzt gleich hier schon zusammen ich kann doch einfach eine klemme nehmen oder
so vielleicht nehme ich einfach so eine klemme da muss ich da da kriege ich den scheiß nämlich
auch wieder auseinander man könnte man könnte so eine klemme nehmen platz platz platz genug
ist da drin ich glaube ich nehme so eine klemme gerade für ground ist das mit der klemme
glaube ich ganz praktisch da kann ich das alles da rein stecken und gut ist müsste eigentlich
ganz ganz sinnig so jetzt bin ich jetzt bin ich bisschen am überlegen mache ich das jetzt
am besten ich mache noch mal kurz diesen knopf hier ab dass das das kriegen wir schon wieder
hin so ich muss jetzt nämlich gucken also wir brauchen fünf volt input ist hier unten
guckt unten links fünf volt input und ground also sprich das muss da so dran aber ich mache
da noch was dazwischen wobei ich habe zweimal ground das müsste eigentlich funktionieren
gucken wir mal wir gucken erst mal ob das angeht wie kriege ich denn das da jetzt am
besten dran ich löte das jetzt einfach direkt an die pins und dann wir müssen es jetzt
nicht übertreiben mit ordentlichkeit wie man hier sieht man muss es nicht übertreiben
mit ordentlichkeit einfach an tag hier mal rumdrehen kann man das nicht drehen gescheit
konnte man konnte man das nicht irgendwie drehen zack und kacke so halten please controller
kommt da in die mit irgendwo ich mache jetzt erst mal dran super super winkel super winkel
ich müsste es eigentlich sieht man noch was ne jetzt sieht man seht ihr nix mehr kurz
rumdrehen seh ich aber wieder nix ja das ist ja geil ne leute ich das muss ich jetzt mal
so machen dass ich was sehe normalerweise würde ich das einfach auf den tisch legen
gut ist aber dass ihr was seht
so da machen wir das jetzt mal dran mache ich das doch mal ab also das ist
aber das ist crap wenn ich das nicht gescheit sehe
so
Hier ist es ordentlich dran, ich hoffe mal, das habe ich halt richtig Low IQ mäßig gemacht
jetzt das war richtig richtig hängen geblieben ich hätte es vorher machen müssen ist auch
bescheuert warum löte ich das dann dran richtig dumm naja gut lässt sich jetzt nicht ändern
kriegst nicht gebacken ja das ist kacke sackt
besser als nix erst mal gucken ob der controller überhaupt angeht jetzt testen wir mal ob der
controller angeht leute also ich habe jetzt das da auf fünf volt und das da auf klaren wenn
ich jetzt den stecker einstecken sollte eigentlich der controller angehen und es sollte nicht rauchen
netzteil mal einstecken wenn sie raucht haben wir was verkehrt gemacht schauen wir mal ist der
controller an schlecht schlecht er blinkt aber er blinkt also der controller blinkt was eigentlich
heißt er ist an aber warum komme ich denn dann nicht auf den vielleicht eine andere ip bekommen
also der blinkt es heißt er müsste an sein aber er kriegt keine aber er zieht sich keine
ip warum nicht wie kann der wie kann der an sein aber das wähler nicht funktionieren jetzt
weiß ich auch nicht dass er die voraussetzungen dafür dass er das da dass wir die weiteren
sachen machen können ich meine dadurch dass der blinkt weiß ich auch dass er geht aber da zieht
sich kein wähler an dann weiß ich nicht mehr ich meine mehr als rein raus stecken kann ich
es ja nicht wir gucken mal was da rauskommt mal kurz ob das ob das funktioniert wartet
mal es sollten fünf voll rauskommen haben wir mal so ground und voll hier funktioniert
ja dann weiß ich auch nicht wie gut es habe ich schon wie gut es habe ich er funktioniert
ja auch erleuchtet ja kann immer rausziehen also es ist es ist richtig es ist auf fünf
volt dem richtigen pin es ist auf ground
der mag nicht sehr merkwürdig der fünf volt pin ist doch input ja muss er ja sonst wird
er nicht leuchten ja genau würde ich fast sagen da ist irgendwas an dem controller verbackt
weil der crown pin hat ja vorher auch schon nicht funktioniert wir schließen es jetzt
nochmal per usb an und gucken ob er sich dann eine adresse zieht schauen wir mal ja ja warum
geht das per usb aber das geht über den 5 volt pin nicht ist irgendwas im arsch jetzt
weiß ich auch nicht was hä vielleicht hat der crown pin da wirklich irgendeinen schaden
da ging ja da ging ja vorhin auch schon nicht nehmen jetzt einfach in den anderen so einmal
probieren was noch einmal probieren was noch da müsste ich jetzt hier schon refreshen
ne ne das ist richtig das ist richtig ok da sind wir dran ich nehme jetzt einen anderen
crown pin ja das das ding blinkt ja das funktioniert aber ich nehme jetzt einen anderen crown pin
ich habe ich habe irgendwie so das gefühl der hat mit dem stimmt irgendwas nicht das
hat den habe ich ja vorhin auch schon versucht zu verwenden und es ging dann irgendwie nicht
es hat dann irgendwie rumgebackt jetzt wäre es halt besser gewesen ich hätte irgendwelche
jumper kabels genommen anstatt den scheiß daran zu löten aber ok ist jetzt halt so
schauen wir mal wo haben wir noch einen crown pin da andere seite der ist auch ordentlich
hier unten hätte wirklich irgendwelche jumper kabels nehmen sollen naja wann machst du
der welcher war es jetzt vielleicht reicht das ja so zum testen mal ob das jetzt angeht
ach kacke man
es war eine blöde idee ich hätte ich hätte gescheite kabels nehmen sollen und nicht
diesen crap hier das kriege ich auch nicht richtig dran ihr seht immer mehr vom fensterbrett
naja was auch immer das wollt ihr auch gerade gar nicht sehen ich will einfach diesen kram
hier dran machen nur zum überprüfen ob es funktioniert lasst es jetzt dran und guck
einfach ob es geht so an den stöpsel gucken ob der jetzt bootet
bringt er denn
das ist der crown pin ich sag's euch doch ich hab's im gefühl gehabt was auch immer
der für schmerzen hatte der crown pin neben dem 5 volt pin geht nicht warum auch immer
das aber merkwürdig das aber merkwürdig funktioniert nice haben wir doch ein crown pin weniger
poggers ok nice also ich weiß wenn ich jetzt ganz trickreich bin dann löte ich das hier
unten dran sodass ich das noch drauf stecken kann oder so
ja funktioniert also keine ahnung was der für probleme hat da ist nichts zum nachlöten
das ist das kommt so geliefert und hier ist auch ganz nichts das passt schon ich lasse
das ding einfach so wie es ist ok das sollte man aber noch mal ordentlich dran machen wobei
das ist erstaunlich fest das zeug was ich hier gebaut habe ja dann nicht dann dann
lass ich das so gut controller passt krieg ich das jetzt irgendwie in die eck der controller
der passt einfach wunderbar irgendwie das ist nicht so viel platz drin hier hier ist
gut hier in die eck im zweifelsfall mach ich da einfach heißkleber drauf dann hältst
so next müssen schalter dran machen schalter für den schalter haben wir noch wo hatten
wir den schalter leute wisst ihr es noch schalter hatten wir gp out 12 glaube ich ne ich glaube
gp out 12 hatten wir den ich hoffe der kam wirklich richtig dran so gp out 12 äh wo ist
denn das jetzt da blickt doch keiner durch wo ist denn das jetzt da ober hier ist 12 gp
out 12 und ground so dann machen wir mal an und gucken ob der schalter funktioniert so
schalter was jetzt was jetzt monka ne der hat sich gezogen das wird der firefox der
rumspackt oder auch nicht er hat sich er hat sich auf jeden fall gezogen was hat der für
schmerz was ist mit dem nicht nicht noch nicht was mit dem los das ist nicht a ja ja ach
jetzt da brauche einfach nur ein bisschen pinkter dann theoretisch ja ok so gucken wir mal ob
der schalter funktioniert klips an ist guckt schalter aus ist schalter funst nice schalter
funst so wie machen wir wie kriegen wir die leds noch dran wir machen jetzt was machen
jetzt als nächstes die leds oder das teil weil für das teil brauche ich zweimal ground
ne doch zweimal zweimal ground das heißt ich muss eh ich muss eh noch irgendwie da
was abzwacken hat er noch nen ground pin irgendwo ach hier hat er noch einen guck mal da hat
er noch einen da machen wir die noch da dran ja 13 14 15 waren für den encoder 15 für
den switch ich glaube schon ja ich glaube ich glaube schon aber ich brauche noch einen
ground den löte ich einfach da unten direkt dran und ruhe ist scheiß drauf mal jetzt keine
esperenzien mehr dann machen wir jetzt hier mal den den den den schalter da rein kurz
gucken dass ich da nicht so sehr drauf drücke und wo ist die schraube da was ist schraube
ist keine schraube wie nennt man das offiziell das keine schraube das ist unterlegscheibe
ist auch nicht was ist denn das
der mutter eine rende mutter jetzt wirds aber advanced hier chat ihr habt recht ich nehme
den ground einfach hier vorn oder das ist richtig park das sieht wirklich aus als könntest
du das eine gut nähe so kaufen nicht aber das sieht wirklich gut aus blub guckt euch
das mal an richtet warnt ja den ground nehmen wir einfach davon genau richtig ja viel besser
dann muss ich dann muss ich mach den einfach hier mit drauf alle ich habe den ground den
unteren genommen ist auch nicht schlimm ist dann tausche ich es einfach so eine flach
mutter es ist gut dass so viele prime gesagt hat man merkt den hohen iq im chat einfach
massiv iq hier höchst höchst iq leistung wieder ok das ist einmal ground und das ist
einmal ground den machen wir dann einfach damit drauf und dann ist alles erledigt so
also plus minus das war glaube ich hier so ich glaube ich glaube so rum hatten wir es
ich bin mir da überhaupt nicht mehr sicher das ist der switch na gut im zweifach dreht
es in die andere richtung dann stöpsel ich es noch mal um so 14 14 13 crown ok das ist
der switch den hatten wir auf 15 glaube wo war 15 noch mal auf der anderen seite 13
links aber ist 15 15 hier massiv massiv china chinesen benahmung so jetzt haben wir noch
zweimal ground die wir irgendwie brauchen die machen einfach mit da drauf wir testen
mal vorher weil wir können vorher nicht testen ob es funktioniert
aber richtig angeschlossen das heißt ich mache das jetzt einfach mal ab habe ich meine
ganzen schönen kabels umsonst umsonst gemacht wir machen das jetzt ab und legen das hier
einfach mit hier drauf und dann ist ruh sollte doch funktionieren die leds machen wir dann
mit hier unten dran und dann dann büßt man eigentlich haben aus so gucken wir mal das
hier ist der da der da ist auf round gut ja dann löten wir die dinge hier oben noch
da zusätzlich dran wir brauchen halt irgendwo was wir haben nicht genug pins dafür muss
ich nur gucken dass ich keine kabel abfackel das wäre ziemlich low brain doch jetzt habe
ich die kabel abgemacht na ganz schlau super massive high IQ egal da machen wir die jetzt
wieder dran mit den anderen doch das wird gefuddelt leute das wird gefuddelt mache
ich das jetzt am besten wie mache ich das jetzt am besten dass ich die da kann ich die
ich meine das darf man vielleicht nicht mal kann ich nicht einfach irgendwie zusammen
machen so einfach so zusammen machen und dann zusammen festlöten und gut ist dann ist halt
ruh alles das easy
da man sieht sie stimmt die kammer hat was mit der kammer los alter das ist die anzeige
na ich höre mich so ähnlich an das stimmt schon kommen wir hier massive dreh action
alles funkt ja richtig das ist ein bisschen weiter ab isolieren
aha poggers ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es richtig richtig fest dran ist jetzt aber ich
würde mal sagen passt so gut nicht schön aber es funktioniert hoffe ich testen wir
mal ob es funktioniert flopp gucken ob es wieder da ist das braucht das braucht ganz
schön lang bis es gebootet ist warum braucht es so lang eigentlich er hat sich auch geholt
keine ahnung warum das so lang zum booten braucht connection to lightfeld ach nee vielleicht
nicht aber booten tut es nicht warum nicht also booten sollte der jetzt eigentlich schon
jetzt war Gott warum braucht der so lang der booted ja fünf stunden alter so das sind wir
also dann wollen wir mal knopf geht encoder geht das ist china chinesen encoder alter encoder
geht knopf farbauswahl geht auch ja leute ich würde sagen es funktioniert alles jetzt
fehlen bloß noch die leds wie kriegen wir die leds da jetzt gescheit dran da die leds
mache ich direkt an den stecker unten dran mit dran dann müssen wir da gucken wir mal
wie man den shit alles hier reinkriegen das ist das hat es halt warum warum wollt ihr
immer dass es raucht warum seid ihr so scharf darauf dass es raucht es hat schon oft genug
geraucht ach ja welchen pin nehmen wir eigentlich für ihr wisst schon datapin für gpi aus
meinauche
So, also wir müssten jetzt noch das Anschlussding, das war bescheuert, das hätte ich gleich
am Anfang mit dran machen sollen.
Das muss hier nämlich auch noch raus irgendwie, aber das mit dem raus, da müssen wir jetzt
gleich noch, wir müssten die LEDs irgendwie rauskriegen.
Leute, was meint ihr, wo ist der beste Ausgang für LEDs, vorne nehmen wir den Knöpfen oder
neben dem Strom, wo machen wir den besten den Ausgang für die LEDs, also für den LED-Stecker.
Weil das sollte ich mir jetzt schon überlegen, bevor ich dann, weil ich kriege ja den Stecker
nicht durch.
Neben dem Strom, hinten beim Strom, also mache ich neben dem Strom, chat, jawoll, hinter
dem Strom, ok.
Gut, sehr schön, jetzt können wir dann, das machen wir China-Chinesen-Style, dann
machen wir einfach ein Dingsheißkleber drauf und dann ist zu.
Oh nein, das war nicht richtig fest Leute, MonkaS, es ist ab, das war nicht gut, aber
nicht verzagen, wir löten jetzt erstmal den Kram hier unten fest, das wird, das wird
fuddelig Leute, das wird fuddelig, ok, das ist Datapin, Zugehtlastung, ja das ist eine
gute Idee, jetzt, oh fuck, das wird, das wird gefuddelt, das hätte ich vorher dran machen
sollen, da habe ich nicht dran gedacht.
Das hätte ich vorher dran machen sollen, mal gucken ob ich da irgendwie noch gescheit
dran komme, hm, ja, ok, kriegst du das irgendwie dran, oh fuck, das wird, das wird was, das
wird was, das da jetzt dran zu bekommen hier unten, lull, gucken wir mal, wir gucken einfach
mal, oh Scheiße, Alter, wie soll ich das da dran kriegen, das ist jetzt gerade 330 Grad,
also, nee, 342 Grad, oh kacke, äh, vielleicht kann ich das einzeln machen, dass das nicht
da drin rumhängt, das ist irgendwie, erst den und dann die anderen, erst so, ah ja,
ah, nee, oh shit, wie kriege ich das da unten jetzt dran, da ist so viel im Weg, hm, ok,
so, das war nicht besser, das war nicht besser, nee, nee, nee, oh fuck, wie kriege ich das
da unten jetzt dran, wir müssen das zweimal dran kriegen, einmal, einmal das rote und
einmal das andere, so, hm, ich versuche es jetzt einfach mal ohne mir die Finger zu verbrennen,
keine Ahnung, ob das funktioniert hat, kacke, nee, oh, Scheiße, man, wie kriege ich das
denn jetzt gescheit hin, daran wird es doch jetzt nicht scheitern, dass ich das Ding da
dran kriege, ok, wie kriegen wir das jetzt gescheit da unten dran, ich komme halt auch
nicht gescheit hin, das ist das Problem, irgendwie so, dass ich bisschen Platz habe, ja, das sieht
doch besser aus, das Dumme ist, ich mache das Kabel im Zweifelsfall ab, was da unten
schon dran hängt, oh, ist das scheiße, man, seht ihr noch alles, das ist mega kacke, kann
ich, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, warte mal, kann ich das drehen, ah, ich
habe es, ah, nice, ich habe es noch nicht so zu fest gemacht, Leute, ich kann es drehen,
das ist schon mal besser, jetzt komme ich da nämlich dran, danach drehen wir es rum und
ich gehe ans andere dran, das ist so gucken, dass ich das andere nicht abmache, ok, na wirklich
gut dran ist, das ist jetzt aber nett, also schön ist was anderes, ich dachte, da ist
Lötzchen von an den Kabeln schon dran, jetzt, oh, das ist gut, das ist gut, jetzt, jetzt
habe ich es dran, ok, nice, ok, sehr schön, sehr schön, so, rumdrehen, jetzt kommt der
andere, ok, so, und jetzt kommt der hier oben, der oben ist ja noch pfummeliger, weil es
noch kleiner ist, ja, wenn sich es löst, ich weiß nicht, wie ich es anders machen
soll gerade, kommt da nicht gescheit dran, ok, das oben ist noch pfummeliger, noch, noch
mehr MonkaS, das hätte ich vorher, ich bin so bescheuert, ich hätte das vorher dran
machen sollen, bevor ich den ganzen Kram eingebaut habe, da habe ich nicht dran gedacht,
aber nachher ist man ja immer bekanntlichermaßen schlauer, machen wir erstmal ein bisschen
Lötzchen dran, dass es dann auch ordentlich hält, so, mal schauen, ok, alter, wie soll
das, das hält auch nie im Leben, das hält auch nie im Leben, was ich da jetzt fabriziert
habe, ok, das hält erstaunlich fest, hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht, das ist erstaunlich
fest, das hätte ich jetzt nicht vermutet, aber ok, ich will mich echt nicht beschweren,
jetzt müssen wir noch die andere Sache fixen, der Kramion ist ja abgegangen, alter, ist das
ein Pains Gem, ja, der Shit ist abgegangen, alter, ist das, ist das ein Rotz, äh, so,
das muss hier durch, das muss da dran, jetzt löte ich das wahrscheinlich wieder ab, Moment,
bevor ich das so mache, langsam, da kommt jetzt erst nochmal, ordentliche Portionen
Lötzchen dran, dass es ordentlich hält, oh fuck man, das hält nicht, jetzt aber, jetzt,
jetzt ist gut, ja, ok, gut, so, es ist alles dran, es fehlt noch ein Pin, wir gucken nochmal
kurz, ob es funktioniert, ob noch alles funzt, es bootet wieder 3 Stunden jetzt, aber ok,
hat sich eine Adresse gezogen, ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung, ok, jetzt gehts schneller, alles
klar, nice, funzt alles, Schalter, ja, Drehstells, ja, ähm, Schalter, Colourstells, ja, nice,
sehr gut, so, das heißt, im Endeffekt, es fehlt jetzt bloß noch der GPIO Pin für die,
für die LEDs, das ist das letzte, was wir dran machen müssen, wo machen wir denn das
dran, hier, der da, den hätte ich wahrscheinlich zuerst machen sollen, wobei, nee, ich glaub,
da mach ichs mir jetzt ein bisschen einfacher, da mach ichs mir jetzt ein bisschen einfacher,
und nehm einfach hier das letzte verbliebene Kabel und steck das, steck das, das Data Cable
drauf, ich löte die Dinger zusammen, steck das da drauf, da muss ich halt aufpassen,
was hinkommt, aber es ist schwierig da wo dran zu kommen, so, gucken wir mal, ob ich
das jetzt irgendwie da dran krieg, weil dann kann ich mir den Rest sparen, exellent, na,
da brauchen wir nämlich, ja, ist auch ordentlich fest, da kann ich jetzt nämlich den GPIO einfach
dran stöpseln und gut ist, so, also, LEDs, LEDs kommen auf GPIO, was ist die vor, GPIO2,
ach was, Schrumpfschlauch, lul, wer braucht sowas, ich mach ein bisschen Heißkleber gleich
drauf, alles Ruhe, ähm, oh, wisst ihr was wir verwenden können, wisst ihr was wir verwenden
können, ich hab so richtig, ich hab so ein nicees Ding, das ist Lötzinn und Schrumpfschlauch
in einem, da kann man, das kann man im Feuerzeug heiß machen, das löte das zusammen und schrumpft
drüber, aber, jetzt erstmal gucken, ob es funktioniert, so, was ist Default, was ist
Default, GPIO2, ich glaube GPIO2, wo ist denn GPIO2, 1, 3, ja, wo ist GPIO2, chat wer findet
ihn da, GPIO2, richtig hängen geblieben, ok, nema 15, hey 15 ist das nema dem gelben,
15 ist nema dem gelben, hier, tatsächlich, GPIO2, Pog, ok, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt,
ob das funktioniert, wir haben alles dran, so, Rollen, machen wir ein bisschen Platz,
ein bisschen Platz und schauen mal, ob es funktioniert, LEDs, LED-Champ, aber wir müssen
die andere Seite nehmen, na super, die innere Seite an den richtigen Stecker, so, also wenn
ich alles richtig eingestellt hab, dann sollen die LEDs jetzt gleich funktionieren, ich muss
aber noch LEDs, ach ne, direkt funktionieren die nicht, weil ich muss noch einstellen,
was, weiß gar nicht, wie viele auf so ner Rolle drauf sind, 100 oder 150 oder so, gucken
wir mal, hey, Leute, da leuchtet was, welches Netzteil, irgendein, was ist denn das, 5 Volt,
10 Ampere, denkst von Amazon, so, da hab ich ein paar davon, also der hat's mit dem
Booten nicht so, das Booten dauert einfach ultralange teilweise, aber er hat sich ne
DHCP-IP gezogen, da ist alles in Ordnung, man braucht's einfach nur, woran das genau
liegt, kein Schimmer, ich mag ja nicht gepinkt zu werden, man weiß ja nie, warum braucht
der denn so lang, der hat sich ja eindeutig den DHCP, ah, jetzt ist er da, ok, WLED,
also config, eben hat er schon mal zumindest kurz gelöscht, also LED-Preferences, GPIO-Nummer,
things, ok, ha, das dumme ist, ich weiß nicht mehr, welche das sind, sind das die, keine
Ahnung, 150, ach was, Brightness-Limiter, Keg-Weight, ja, safe, jetzt sollten die LEDs
eigentlich funktionieren, wenn ich's richtig gemacht hab, wobei eben die sind ja eben schon
mal kurz angegangen, aber dann wieder aus, vielleicht ist das auch wegen dem User-Mod,
dass das so lang dauert, ach, ach, die Brightness war im Arsch, ok, die Anzeige stimmt einfach
nicht, Achtung, Moment, ich mach mal kurz aus, da wirklich gut erkennen tut man's nicht,
Häh, das hat irgendwelche Schmerzen, guck mal, das restartet sich zwischendurch, das
hat definitiv irgendwelche Probleme, voll, ich mach noch mal ein bisschen aus, Decke
aus, ok, er zieht mal ein bisschen was, angeblich 150, das sind, das sind, wobei, ich hab die
richtigen, guck mal, wir können testen, ob ich die richtigen hab, blau, ja, grün, ja,
rot, ja, dann hab ich die richtigen, aber sind definitiv bisschen wenige LEDs an, oder,
es müssten eigentlich deutlich mehr sein, ah, ich weiß woran das liegt, wegen den Presets,
die Presets sind RIP, jaja, die Presets sacken, wir brauchen hier Delete, Delete, Delete Preset,
die Einstellungen sind verbuggt, oder ich hab's verkehrt gemacht, also, ich glaube, es sind
nur 100, ich glaube, es sind nur 100, safe, und, nee, das ist, ich weiß nicht, wie viele
das sind, das war, das mit den Presets, die Presets sind buggen grad rum, guck mal, jetzt
sind's auch mehr, jetzt sind's auch mehr, sind aber noch nicht alle, ok, wie viel haben
wir denn, config, ich weiß gar nicht, wieviel sind's, 200, ich weiß es gar nicht, safe,
immer noch nicht alle, sind's 300, oh, MonkaS, MonkaS, oh, oh, oh, Leute, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, der Controller hat, äh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, das ist, weil der Controller ausgeht,
ja, ja, der Controller kriegt nicht genug ab, das müssen wir anders machen, ähm, wir
haben erstmal Licht wieder an, Decke, was los, Licht ein, jawoll, so, ich hab das bestimmt
nicht richtig angeschlossen, also zu dumm angeschlossen, weil normalerweise ist es ja
so gedacht, hier machst du die Spannung drüber, aber das müsste eigentlich doch passen, ich
meine, der Controller ist da, ich mach mal den, ich mach mal den Spannungslimiter rein,
vielleicht ist es einfach zu krass dafür, für das Netzteil, was auch immer, das ist
eigentlich direkt hier vorne dran, das sollte eigentlich kein Problem sein, schau mal mal,
du musst beide unabhängig, wie, wie soll, wie soll das denn anders, wie soll das denn
vor, anders vorstellen, ich hab beide direkt an den Stecker gelötet, äh, mehr unabhängig
ist, kann ich die nicht anschließen, IP liegt, MonkaS, jetzt ist vorbei, jetzt ist vorbei
Leute, vielleicht ist das Netzteil einfach auszuschalten, brightness limiter, ok, hauptsinn,
das ist doch 300, hauptsinn, äh, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
Ist das eigentlich da?
Ach ne, gar nix.
Okay, reicht das jetzt so?
Können wir die brightness ein bisschen runter?
Brightness ein bisschen runter, okay.
Oh, war mal rot, das brauch am wenigsten.
Darf nicht mit den Presets rum, so, jetzt schließen wir es nochmal an.
Ist jetzt wieder ausgegangen.
Warum?
Was hat der für Probleme?
Hm.
Wie geht's denn?
Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, wie ich das anders großartig anschließen soll.
Ich weiß, warum das so ist, weiß aber nicht, was ich anders machen soll.
Wobei ich hab's jetzt doch schon limitiert, also mehr sollte das jetzt eigentlich...
Nee, nee, nee, das muss eigentlich gehen. Ich hab irgendwas verkehrt und bescheuert angeschlossen,
aber von der Idee her kann da eigentlich jetzt so viel gar nicht verkehrt sein.
Ich mein, das ist beides direkt am Stecker. Ich mein, mehr geht ja kaum.
Es wird ja auch ganz schön warm, ehrlich gesagt. Also die Kabels und so,
die werden auch relativ warm, also... Rest jetzt nicht.
Wie geht's denn mit dem Stecker hier vom Netzteil aus? Ist der vielleicht einfach kacke?
Nö, das ist alles kühl. Ja, das sind ja keine 17 Ampere. Da steht ja da.
Wenn ich da jetzt mal was dran mache, dann ist das schon deutlich weniger.
Okay, wir machen das mal anders. Wir machen mal die LEDs runter. Ich hatte ja schon so
welche da dran. Wie viel sind denn das noch mal? Ich glaube 300. Wie heißen die Dinger? B, T, F,
Lighting oder sowas? Ja, sowas hier in der Richtung ist das so ein 5 Meter, 300. Ich
hatte das mehr oder weniger mit dem gleichen Setup da ja schon dran.
Wobei das Limit geht doch nur, wenn ich das über die GPIOs vom ESP mache, oder? Das mache ich ja
zum Glück nicht. Aber mit 50 wird es wahrscheinlich funktionieren.
Ja, also 50 ist kein Ding. 50 geht. Das muss ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen irgendwie müsste
ich das anders anschließen. Ich habe aber keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt. Wie? Weil ich meine,
das ist beides direkt am Stecker. Mehr bringt es. Also anscheinend macht das Netzteil nicht
mehr mit. What the fuck? Genau, das ist nur wenn du über den ESP gehst. Tja. Ich habe
keine Ahnung. 50 gehen. Mehr hat ein Problem. Was merkwürdig ist, weil ich habe ja selbst
schon mal, also an meinem Fenster habe ich das ja genauso angeschlossen. Nur,
dass ich dann hier drüber gemacht habe mit dem Strom. Da ist doch irgendwas. Irgendwas ist
doch da scheiße. Guck mal. Da ist doch irgendwas im Arsch, wenn das sich zwischendrin auch immer
an- und ausschaltet. Erzähl mir doch nichts von wegen 17 Ampere. Das brauchst du im Leben
nicht. Das Ding ist auf 30 Prozent, 30 Prozent Brightness und auf Gelb. Das braucht nie im
Leben 17 Ampere. Und außerdem für 50 LEDs schon mal gar nicht. Da macht es ja auch schon
Probleme. Das ist nur Estimate im Webinterface. Das funktioniert. Ich habe das gleiche Netzteil
an meinem Fenster angeschlossen und das funktioniert. Das liegt eigentlich an meinem Kabelstelz,
was ich hier mache, der für ein Arsch ist. Irgendwas mit meinem Verkabelungsgrab nicht
richtig. Das liegt nicht am Netzteil und das liegt auch nicht an den LEDs. Das liegt
an meinem Verkabelungsgrab, wobei ich da legit keine Ahnung habe, was ich großartig anders
verkabeln soll. Nein, ich habe kein Oszilloskop da, wozu auch. Hm. Das ist ja geil. Also ich
meine, guck mal, ich habe den ganzen Mist direkt am Stecker dran. Also mehr Probleme
soll es eigentlich nicht geben. Ich bin ja kurz davor zu sagen, ich mache mal alles ab,
was ich da sonst noch so dran habe. Machen wir das ganze Zeug ab, was ich da sonst noch
dran habe. Und wir machen nur, wir machen mal nur den Kram dran, den wir für die LEDs
brauchen. Das ist alles, was wir für die LEDs brauchen. Guck mal, da kann nicht wirklich
viel falsch sein. Direkt am Stecker. Wisst ihr, was ich jetzt noch mal mache? Wisst ihr,
was ich jetzt noch mal mache? Ich löte das Zeug noch mal ab, mache den Stecker raus und
löte das noch mal richtig ordentlich an den Stecker dran, aber an den anderen. Und dann
gucken wir mal, ob das immer noch so ist. Wenn das dann immer noch so ist, dann ist
irgendwas vielleicht doch mit dem Netzteil. Ich meine, das ist zwar genau das gleiche
Netzteil, ich zeige es euch mal. Das ist zwar genau das gleiche Netzteil, wie ich am Fenster
dran habe, aber vielleicht hatte das Netzteil irgendeinen Schaden, keine Ahnung. Das ist
mehr als genug. Ich habe gerade kein anderes da, das am Fenster ist, durch die Wand durch,
also in so einem Kanal, das kriege ich nicht raus. Ich mache das mal ab, ich mache das
noch mal ab. Scheiß drauf jetzt. Wenn es mit LEDs nicht funktioniert, dann mache ich
das halt dann. Egal, LEDs müssen funktionieren. Anderes gibt es nicht.
So, gut. Dann machen wir nochmal das Ding hier ab. Wenn ich das da irgendwie rauskriege,
null. So, das ab und jetzt irgendwie noch den, mal kurz das Teil hier raus. So, und
jetzt machen wir das mal unabhängig. Das hätte ich eigentlich als allererstes machen
sollen, um zu gucken, ob der Scheiß überhaupt funktioniert. So, also das ist ordentlich
dran. Gut, da wollen wir mal. Also beides, wenn du eine Idee hast, sag Bescheid, aber
ich wüsste, wie gesagt, ich wüsste nicht, was verkehrt sein sollte. So, dann machen
wir das mal. Kann das mal warm werden, please. Perfekt. Okay, besser dran geht das Kabel
wirklich nicht. Das ist Porgas dran. Mehr dran kann es eigentlich nicht. Der ganze Aufbau
ist ja gerade relativ easy. Es ist gerade überhaupt kein Aufbau eigentlich. Muss das nur noch
dran bleiben. Ja, Kabel. Ah, Kabel, Kabel, Kabel, Kabel. Du, du, du. Besser Kacke.
Das ist ja richtig reutig hier. Ja, das ist auch richtig, richtig ordentlich dran. Da
geht nichts. Gut. So, und jetzt noch die zwei hier. Ich meine, wir können auch einfach
die zwei hier vorne irgendwo dran machen oder so. Ja. So, den hier mal gerade.
Okay, das ist mal richtig fest jetzt.
Also, das macht keiner so ein so easy mal ab. Das ist richtig fest. So, und jetzt machen
wir hier noch den, den da dran. Ich hätte das halt mal mit gescheiten Jumperkabel machen
sollen, da hätte ich jetzt nicht dieses gefuddelt. Aber gut, nachher bist schlauer. Gott, das
ist ein mega Gefrickel, Alter. Gut. Exzellent. Fuck. Ab.
Das kriegt man halt richtig scheiße. Das ist Kacke, Mann, das geht nicht richtig
ran. Wo habe ich mein Lötzchen hin?
Chat, wo ist mein Lötzchen? Das habe ich irgendwo reingeschmissen, weil ich mir gedacht
habe, wir sind jetzt fertig. Ach, hier oben. Ha.
Ich will nur einfach nur, meine Fresse, bleib halt dran. Der braucht, der muss einfach dran
sein, dass ich das mal einschalten kann. Das ist richtig dumm. Hätte ich anders machen
müssen. Da bin ich am Anfang. Das ist halt einfach scheiße. Das ist so scheiße, Mann,
das ist so scheiße. Das ist so scheiße, Mann, das ist so scheiße.
Jetzt habe ich da drei Kilo Lötzchen drauf, jetzt ist es dran. Gut, nice. Jetzt ist Bombenfest.
Okay. Das, das, das. GPIO, was habe ich gesagt? Zwei. Hier, so, GPIO 2. So, Strom dran. Strom
dran. Zack. So, jetzt sollte es booten. Was hast du für die Hammer Steckdosen bezahlt?
Boah. Weiß ich nicht mehr. Keine Ahnung. Das habe ich glaube ich im Stream gesagt.
Keine Ahnung, 30 Euro oder so, kann das sein? Irgendwie sowas? So. Ah nee, falsche Seite,
null. Ja, super. Wie es einfach direkt ausgeht, ich glaube echtes liegt am Netzteil. Ich glaube
langsam echtes liegt am Netzteil, ohne Scheiß. Ups. Ich glaube echtes liegt am Netzteil.
Ich habe ein Multimeter, aber ich habe da jetzt kein Bock großartig rum zu wurschteln.
Machen wir nur, damit es der Oberlicht keinen Kurzschluss gibt. So. Wir machen jetzt mal
die LEDs ein bisschen runter. Config, LED Preference, ja komm 20, 20 muss reichen.
Save. So. Aha. In welchen Gründen biegt sich das? So, also das mit, das Funst, das
Funst. So. LED. Nein. Wi-Fi Setup. Nein, nicht Wi-Fi Setup. LED Preferences. So, 50.
Save. Bäm, funktioniert. LED Preferences 100. Bäm, funktioniert. LED Preferences 300.
Wenn es jetzt funktioniert, weiß ich woran es gelegen hat. Bäm. Oh, und der ESP ist
aus. Okay. Fast, fast. Legt das wirklich am Netzteil vielleicht? Ich habe, wie gesagt,
ich habe exakt das gleiche, so wie es ist, genau das gleiche Netzteil bei mir am Fenster
und da funktioniert alles wunderbar. Sehr komisch. Nein, ich messe da jetzt nichts.
Na gut, das werden wir heute wahrscheinlich nicht mehr gelöst kriegen. 50. Ähm, wartet
mal. Presets. Create Default Preset. Ich will, dass der mit kleinerer Brightness startet.
LED Preferences. Preset 1. So, und wenn ich die jetzt noch höre, weil der soll, der soll
die mal dunkel machen, relativ dunkel und dann will ich gucken, ob es funst. Okay,
ich stöpseln mal an. Gut. Config. Es legt da nur jetzt der Chorm. Wenn das, jetzt funst
das, wenn ich das heller mache, ich wette mit euch, wenn ich das heller mache, geht
es aus. Wir machen mal rot. Rot braucht ja wenigstens Energie. Bäm. Bäm. Okay, aus
irgendwelchen Gründen funst das, haut das mit dem Netzteil nicht hin. Was sehr, sehr
merkwürdig. Ich hab genau, ich hab wirklich genau das, ich hab das doppelt bestellt.
Das ist die gleiche Amazon Bestellung, wo ich das am Fenster hab. Und das reicht. Hm.
Ich kann noch mal eine Sache einstellen, wo ich weiß, dass es weniger Strom braucht.
Wenn man das, es ist so dunkel, ich seh nix. Wo haben wir denn das Kabel? Hier. Was funktioniert
es, wenn man ja Brightness runter und Effekte Handle Multi? Das ist auch ganz gut. Nee,
das bringt glaub ich nix. Okay. Handle Multi tut. So. Config. Na, was will ich? Alter,
was will ich denn alles auf Wi-Fi Setup? LED. 200. Save. Bäm. LED Preferences 300.
Save. Bäm. Warum geht der Rest jetzt nicht an? Warum geht der Rest jetzt nicht an? Eigentlich
sollten jetzt alle LEDs angehen. Fuck, oder was? Wahrscheinlich, weil es hier nur 150
waren. LED Preferences 300. Standard Brightness 20 oder so, was man noch standardmäßig macht,
keine Ahnung. Save. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen mag der jetzt gar nicht mehr alle LEDs anmachen.
Das reicht. Wie ich bereits 50.000 Mal gesagt hab, Chet, ich hab exakt das gleiche Netzwerk
mit exakt dem gleichen Abbau bei mir am Fenster. Außerdem ist das nur bei Weiß, beziehungsweise
wenn du volle Helligkeit machst und Weiß. Das ist Rot und 20% Helligkeit. Seit man nicht
so 3 hat, also wirklich jetzt. Warum gehen jetzt überhaupt nicht alle an? Was ist denn
das für ein Scheiß? Ahja, okay. Ahja. Jaja, ich hab genau das gleiche.
Bäm. Äh. Okay. Ja, das ist das nicht, das ist
das Netzteil. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was, ob das Netzteil irgendeinen Schaden hat oder
so. Keine Ahnung. Das funzt jetzt wegen. Nee, jetzt ist es auch solid. Jetzt blick ich
schnell mal durch. Wir machen jetzt, das braucht nämlich weniger. Colors. Wir machen jetzt
weiß. Oder blau. Weiß. Dark Seed muss aus. Weiß. Okay, weiß ist blau. Aha, siehst du,
habt ihr es gesehen. Das ist das Netzteil. Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum. Ich hab legit
keinen Blastschimmer. Was das Netzteil für Schmerzen hat im Vergleich zu dem anderen,
das ich am Fenster hab. Aber es ist offensichtlich. Ich mach das Ding auf weiß und volle Pulle
und es kackt ab. Zumindest teilweise. Ja, ich, okay, das, das liegt am Netzteil. Sehr,
sehr komisch. Aber gut, wissen wir wenigstens, woran es liegt. Das ist doch schon mal gut.
Naja, gut. Aber zumindest, zumindest sollte der ganze Spaß in. Also, wenn man zum Beispiel
sagt, hier, guck mal, wenn man sagt Effekte, dann nehmen wir mal irgendwie irgendwas, was,
sowas da, wo nicht, wo nicht alle an sind. Guck, dann, dann, dann funzt das ja auch wunderbar.
Oder oder zum Beispiel sowas da, wo das braucht deutlich weniger. Kann das Netzteil am Fenster
nicht verwenden dafür. Das geht durch so ein Kabelkanal durch. Guck, wunderbar. Aber
es ist klar, das verbraucht natürlich auch deutlich weniger Strom jetzt, weil da sind
nur immer einzelne LEDs an. Da kann ich volle Helligkeit machen. Sehr komisch. Ich mein,
der Unterschied ist. Das könnte, das könnte es sogar wirklich sein. Auch wenn ich nicht
genau verstehe, warum. Der Unterschied ist, ich glaube, ich hatte am Fenster ähnliche
Probleme, aber der ESP war an der anderen Seite. Und zwar man kann, man kann, ich mach
mal kurz groß. Man kann an der anderen Seite, also hier, hier, kann man auch, das sollte
ich nicht vielleicht hier zusammen kommen jetzt, hier kann man auch nochmal Power injecten
von beiden Seiten. Das könnte es stabiler machen, wobei ich das nicht so genau verstehe.
Weil der ESP ist auf der Seite. Aber das habe ich am Fenster auch. Am Fenster habe ich das
auch so, da habe ich Power an beiden Seiten dran, nicht nur an einer Seite. Das könnte
man auch ausprobieren. Aber nicht heute, weil, was ist schon, Chat? Was ist es? Es ist, wobei
das ist doch total einfach. Guck dir mal, ich mach hier einfach zwei Klemmen dran. Lul,
Leute, das machen wir noch. Das ist easy. Komm mal, das ist easy Mode. Äh, hier. Klemmen
so. Klemmen so. Wirst doch eigentlich so funktionieren, ne? Das geht ja dann, geht ja da dran. Schon
spät, genau. So, jetzt haben wir nämlich Strom an beiden Seiten. Und vielleicht geht
es jetzt auch besser. Schauen wir mal. Mhm, mhm. Äh, hm. Du, du, du, du, du, du, du,
du, du, du, du, du. So, ich mache jetzt den gleichen Effekt, den ich bei mir am Fenster
auch immer gerne verwende. Das ist der hier. Candlestells. Machen wir mal weiß, das ist
volle Pulle. Na komm, oh hier, den da. So. Hä. Das, ah ne, Mist, RIP. RIP. Ok Leute, ich
hab keine Ahnung, woran das liegt. Beim besten Willen nicht. Gleiches Ding, am Fenster geht,
ESP geht nicht. Naja. Ich bin mir sogar ziemlich sicher, dass ich sogar den gleichen ESP32
am Fenster habe. Auf der anderen Seite ist das ja durchaus in Ordnung, wenn es bei voller
Geschichte crasht, das will ich ja eh nicht machen. Das ist jetzt ja nur zum Testen. Erklärt
es nicht, warum es vorher schon bei 20 LEDs in Geisthoff gegeben hat. Na gut, wie dem
auch sei, Chet, jetzt ist schon spät und jetzt gehe ich ins Bett. Schön, dass ihr
alle dabei gewesen seid, aber jetzt ist Bettge-Time. Wir sehen uns, bis denn, CU, Bettge, genau.